Ja, ich bin schon seit zwei Stunden wach.
Also ich muss nicht unbedingt aufwachen.
Wobei wirklich, wenn ich anhat.
Lulwe.
Lulwe ist immer noch größer Kekwe.
Eindeutig.
Kann ich was alle an Kekwe finden.
Gibt es eigentlich beim Steam?
Ist doch irgendwie gerade wieder Winter, Winter Sale oder so.
Oder ist es schon vorbei?
Ich meine, es ist eh nichts dabei, was ich mir kaufen werde.
Also insofern.
Moin, KTG, Chris.
Ich kaufe mir eh nichts bei Steam irgendwie.
Es gibt so viel Bullshit bei Steam mittlerweile,
dass in dem Meer von Bullshit
findest du kaum noch irgendwie gescheite Sachen.
Steam ist mittlerweile 90% Shit.
Sag dir dazu.
Der Typ hat Snake auf seine Weile.
Weihnachtsbaum programmiert.
Wenn du so die Apple Werbung kriegst, dann musst du Twitch fragen.
Oder besser gesagt, deine Viewing History musst du fragen.
Scheinbar bist du Apple Fan.
Oder zumindest interessiert an Apple.
Die wissen das besser als du.
Aber das ist doch wirklich Next Level Pock, oder?
Der Typ mit seinem Weihnachtsbaum, wo man Snake mit dem PS4 Controller spielen kann.
Moin, was hältst du von Interlux?
Das ist doch nicht schlecht.
Allerdings habe ich bis jetzt noch kein Anwendungsgebiet dafür gefunden, wo ich einen gebraucht hätte oder gewollt hätte.
Also coole Sache ist es ja.
Leider nur in Rot.
Das wäre natürlich cool.
Was halt richtig cool ist, dass du oben rausfahren kannst und unten wieder reinkommst.
Es wäre natürlich cooler,
wenn er das mit,
was weiß ich, so mit RGBs gemacht hätte.
Also es sind garantiert irgendwelche RGB-LEDs.
Dass es nicht nur Rot wäre, sondern dass man das
dass die Farbe wechseln würde, schneller, langsamer wird das.
Aber cool ist es.
Cool ist es, muss man sagen.
Ich meine nicht, dass es was bringt, ja.
Aber es geht.
Das ist das Wichtigste.
Ich finde das schon nice.
Ich will lieber Bad Company 3.
Ja, Top-Vergleich.
Snake auf dem Weihnachtsmann oder, ähm, auf dem...
Snake auf dem Weihnachtsmann, oder?
Snake auf dem Weihnachtsbaum
oder Bad Company 3.
Ja, weil das ja auch so Sachen sind, die man so direkt...
miteinander vergleichen muss.
Ich hätte gerne lieber Bad Company 3 gehabt,
als die letzten zwei Battlefield-Main-Games.
James Ryan, guck dir einfach das Max-Reveal aus der Peking-Suppe an.
Oder guck dir irgendwelche Videos...
Es gab mittlerweile einige Videos, wo ich drin rumgesprungen bin.
Auf Gamescom-Videos bin ich drin rumgesprungen.
Das hat bloß keiner gecheckt.
Auf Battlefield-Videos bin ich schon drin rumgesprungen.
Hat bloß keiner kapiert, ja.
Tja...
Ich trau mich gar nicht, auf die Reddit-Frontpage zu gucken.
Weiß gar nicht, warum ich die aufgemacht hab.
Ich glaub...
Nee, war nix Schlimmes.
Aber irgendwie...
Die Reddit-Frontpage ist immer schwierig im Stream zu zeigen.
Weiß man nie so genau, was da auf einmal drauf ist.
Wir spielen jetzt...
Oder nee, nicht jetzt.
Nachher mal.
Spielen wir mal hier...
Das hab ich vorhin auf dem Handy gefunden.
Äh...
Guess the Programming Language.
Du kriegst ein Hello World-Snippet und musst raten, was für eine Programmiersprache es ist.
Und es ist wirklich schwierig.
Was die sollten...
Battlefield 5 beenden und sich hauptsächlich auf Battlefield 6 basieren.
Die sollten vor allem mal ein gescheites neues Battlefield machen.
Eigentlich ist mir vollkommen wurscht, wie das Ganze heißt.
Battlefield 5 ist ja mittlerweile angeblich ganz okay.
Wobei es der letzte Patch wohl wieder richtig verkackt haben muss.
Ich glaube, dass wir das jetzt mal hören sagen.
Ich spiel das ja selbst nicht.
Und dann gucken wir ein bisschen Mario Kart.
Dann gucken wir ein bisschen YouTube.
Die Witcher-Serie scheint schwer angesagt zu sein.
Ich hab immer noch kein Netflix.
Ich hab immer noch kein Netflix-Account geholt.
Ich überleg mal, ob ich wirklich mal ein Netflix-Probeabo mache, um die Witcher-Serie anzugucken.
Interessiert mich jetzt ein 6600k.
Das ist ja...
Outdated, overrated, jebaited.
Sag mal...
Sag mal, Leute.
Einzige Frage.
Bin ich der Einzige, der sich irgendwie Alexi Baxi nicht angucken kann?
Ich verstehe überhaupt nicht, was einem diese Videos geben.
Der hat glaube ich nicht wirklich Ahnung von Technik.
Die Art und Weise, wie die Videos gemacht werden, ist übelst überdreht und nervig.
Ich kann mir das nicht angucken.
Ich weiß nicht, warum man sich das anguckt.
Aber...
Gut.
Je dem das sei, naja.
Das sagen genauso viele über meine Videos.
Wahrscheinlich.
Alter, Max, du hast Spaß da.
Haben Sie auch recht.
Lul, weh.
Relaxing Nintendo Music.
Oh, das ist gut.
Komm, wir hören uns lieber Relaxing Nintendo Music an, als Wub-Wub-Wub.
Ah, yes.
Excellent Piano.
Excellent.
Was haben sie denn da drinnen?
Ach, komm.
Wir gucken mal was.
Wie viele Wub-Wub-Wub-Mixe...
Mixe.
Pff.
Wir haben vollen Krieg, ja.
Mixe.
Where did Soundcards go?
Das ist ganz einfach.
Auf dem Mainboard.
Als wären die weg.
Was denn?
So hässliche Erweiterungs-PCI-Karten hat kein Mensch mehr.
Wozu auch?
So ein bisschen digitalen Analog-Converter und schlechter Audioausgang kann man auch
auf dem Mainboard machen.
Daniel Lull.
Sechs Monate.
Uiuiui.
Miese Abo-Fallen, ja.
Wonka Toss.
Da sagst du nicht so laut, ja.
Dankeschön.
Pock.
So.
Bad Guys of 2000...
What's the worst CPU and GPU Purchases of 2000?
Weiß nicht, ob das so interessant ist.
Wir können mal kurz drüber skippen.
Diablo 4 juckt mich überhaupt nicht.
Ganz ehrlich, wenn ich irgendwie wieder mal in Hack and Slay oder in so einem Action-RPG
Hack and Slay spielen möchte, dann würde ich wieder Path of Exile spielen.
Diablo ist bei mir...
Ist vorbei.
Forgotten Battle Royale Game.
Ist das F...
H1...
Z1 oder...
Nee, das ist irgendwas anderes.
Ach nee, das ist Firestorm, ne?
Firestorm, oder?
Ist das Firestorm?
Was kein Mensch mehr spielt.
Warte mal.
Twitch.
Firestorm.
Ach, Moment.
Nee.
Es hieß gar nicht Firestorm.
Wie hieß das?
Was?
Ähm...
Doch, oder?
Hieß doch Firestorm.
Ah, das ist gar keine eigene Kategorie.
Oh!
Der meistgeschaute Battlefield-Kanal hat 101 Zuschauer.
Zuschauer, uiuiuiuiuiui, das Game ist aber voll angesagt.
Huge Erfolg, würde ich sagen.
Leute haben sich das Game vielleicht gekauft, aber spielen tut es anscheinend keiner mehr.
Man kann es zwar nicht immer direkt aus der Beliebtheit auf Twitch ableiten, wie beliebt ein Game ist,
aber es hängt auf jeden Fall zusammen.
Es hängt 100 pro zusammen.
In der Regel sind Spiele, die gut laufen, auch Spiele, die viel auf Twitch geguckt werden und umgedreht.
Wie kann man legal spenden? Du kannst mich einfach abonnieren auf Twitch, wenn du was spenden willst.
Du kannst auch einfach über meinen Reflekt bei Amazon irgendwas einkaufen oder einfach nichts machen und zugucken.
Das ist alles umsonst.
Ich meine, ich mache ja auch nichts. Ich sitze da und gucke ein bisschen Zeug an.
Daniel Lull, dich hatte ich schon, ne?
Also das sind sechs Monate.
Warte hier. Excellent. Big Brain Sub.
So, wir...
Alter, ich hab ja irgendwas im Hals.
Kostenloses Entertainment. Never sub, never subscribe.
Free Neighbor WiFi, free WLAN, stolen laptop, free entertainment.
Leute, ihr könnt...
Wenn ihr schon copy-pasten wollt, dann müsst ihr richtig copy-pasten.
Ja.
Den da braucht ihr.
Never sub, never donated, Adblock on stone, laptop, Neighbor's WiFi, free entertainment.
Wenn schon, dann richtig, ja?
Wenn schon copy-pasten, dann richtig.
Wisst ihr, was das Schlimme ist?
Mittlerweile traue ich mich gar nicht mehr bei Google, wenn man irgendwas Twitch-related ist.
Wenn man...
Alter, keiner sagt es wieder.
Wenn man irgendwas mit Bezug auf Twitch in Google eingibt,
traue ich mich mittlerweile gar nicht mehr auf die Bilder suchen.
Weil, es gibt mittlerweile so viele leicht begleitete Damen auf Twitch
und die nicht nur, muss man dazu sagen, die nicht nur auf Twitch aktiv sind,
sondern durchaus auch auf anderen Plattformen.
Ähm, wenn du auf Bildersuche klickst, kann das durchaus sein, dass du hier, äh, Monkatos-Probleme kriegst, ja?
Da muss man aufpassen.
Und wisst ihr, an was mich das erinnert?
Dieses Geflöte.
Könnt ihr euch noch an das...
Ach, das ist ja...
Skyward Sword, genau.
Ähm, könnt ihr euch noch an das Geflöte von Ubisoft erinnern?
Haha, der Flöten-Guy, der Flöten-Typ bei Ubisoft.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, für welches Game das war.
Für irgend so ein...
Irgendein, ja...
Für was für ein Game war das eigentlich nochmal?
War das hier der Flöten-Typ?
Oh ja, hier.
Und es ging halt irgendwie drei Minuten oder so.
Und es ging halt ewig, ja?
So, äh, A Ghost...
Ist das eigentlich mittlerweile raus?
Ach, nee, nee, nee, okay, es dauert noch.
Es dauert noch.
Der Flöten-Typ war schon geil, Alter.
Ähm...
Naja, äh, Game-Trailer gucken wir an Silvester wieder an.
Was 2020 so rauskommt.
Okay, nee, das ist noch nicht released.
Alles klar.
Den Curved Monitor, ja?
DuckDuckGo, ich verwende mittlerweile fast nur noch...
Ähm, zumindest auf den Handys oder Tablets.
Fast nur noch DuckDuckGo verwende ich.
Kaum noch Google da.
Prima.
Und, ähm...
Übrigens, ich hab was richtig...
Einen richtig nicen Browser gefunden.
Für iOS.
Wobei ich mir nicht sicher bin, wie sicher das Ding ist.
Also sprich, wo der überall Daten hinschickt.
Und zwar, ähm...
Der Name ist schon absolut G-Bait.
Ja?
Also der Name ist schon mega G-Bait.
Das Ding hier, ähm...
Weil, also, mir ist das vollkommen egal.
Jetzt ist das hier irgendwie mit...
Also, der Z-Block funktioniert auch nur halb.
Nicht Brave. Brave hab ich auch lange benutzt.
Brave hat ein Problem.
Wofür ich eigentlich andere Browser verwende.
Als Safari.
Nämlich Sachen,
dass ich YouTube und Twitch im Hintergrund abspielen kann.
Und das ist der einzige Browser,
den ich gefunden habe bisher für iOS.
Der aktuell noch,
Opera Mini ist ja nicht mehr im App Store.
Der
im Hintergrund
Twitch und YouTube abspielen kann.
Es sieht übelst nach...
nach China...
Es sieht übelst nach China G-Bait aus.
Ich würde mich da auch niemals
mit irgendeinem...
Die Twitch App kann sowas,
aber die YouTube App kann sowas nicht.
Und die Twitch App hat Werbung.
Trotz Twitch Prime.
So, und das Schöne an dem Browser ist,
auf Twitch funktioniert der Adblock.
Das heißt, man kriegt keine Werbung.
Und kann im Hintergrund abspielen.
Und auf YouTube ist der Adblock ein bisschen kaputt.
Aber dafür funktioniert im Hintergrund abspielen.
Was die YouTube App nicht kann.
Das ist eigentlich ein ganz guter Kompromiss.
Ich würde mich da im Leben nicht mit irgendeinem Account anmelden.
Weil das...
Allein schon der Name...
Sieht nach China...
Keine Ahnung...
Allein schon, weil das Ding Private Browser heißt.
Da kannst du dir davon ausgehen,
da ist überhaupt nichts private.
YouTube...
Was bringt mir ein APK auf einem iPhone?
Ja, du kannst YouTube Premium kaufen,
aber YouTube Premium ist der Witz.
Ähm...
Wenn du überlegst...
Also erstens mal...
Ich mein...
12 Euro!
Dafür krieg ich Netflix und Amazon Musik.
Oder...
Spotify und...
Da krieg ich 2 Abos dafür.
Ich mein, 12 Euro!
Und was...
Du kriegst dafür ja nix!
Du kriegst YouTube...
Das ist Ibaro wieder.
Das ist mal klar.
Was man für ein paar Euro kriegt, okay.
Ähm...
Aber du kriegst ja im Prinzip nix dafür.
Gibt's eigentlich YouTube Red noch?
Oder ist das jetzt auch Premium, ne?
Also ich mein, du kriegst ja nix dafür im Endeffekt.
Du kriegst Head Free?
Okay. Ja, okay.
Ähm... Background Play.
Das ist der absolut lächerlichste Grund überhaupt.
Ja?
Das ist der...
Ja, aber Music Premium hast du sonst nicht.
Das kannst du ja auch downloaden und sowas.
Aber Background Play hier überhaupt anzupreisen,
ist das lächerlichste überhaupt.
Weil das...
Das einzige, was das sagt, dass die hier Background Play anpreisen, ist,
wir haben ein absolutes Basic Feature genommen,
was früher jede 0815
Kack-App konnte,
haben es ausgebaut,
oder absichtlich nicht erneuert,
sodass es funktioniert.
Ähm...
Um es dann als Premium Feature anzupreisen.
Also das ist das absolut lächerliche.
Ich verstehe nicht, weil die müssen irgendwie Geld verdienen, okay?
Aber Background Play hier anzupreisen, ist lächerlich.
Ähm...
Das ist auch der Grund, warum ich YouTube App nicht mehr verwenden will.
Downloads.
Ist auch so ein Basic Feature,
was auch...
Ich suche nicht nach O-Block.
Ähm...
Ist auch so ein Basic Feature,
wo man sich denkt, was ist daran Premium?
Diese...
Also das hier und das hier,
die zwei Sachen, die hier angepriesen werden,
für 12 Euro im Monat,
sind Basic Features,
die jede Player App
besitzen sollte, und
die nicht bereitgestellt werden,
und die nicht schwierig zu programmieren sind.
Also man soll 12 Euro für irgendwas bezahlen,
was einer in 45 Minuten eingebaut hat.
Ja, ich weiß,
unter Android ist das Ganze kein Problem,
unter Android gibt es genug Varianten.
Aber es geht mir jetzt ja gerade ums iPhone.
Ich habe schon mal geguckt vor einer Weile,
ob es nicht irgendwelche
Squid oder Proxy Extensions gibt,
die Adblock machen, aber
das ist halt wegen,
weil das mittlerweile alles über SSL läuft,
nicht so einfach.
Würde theoretisch, wahrscheinlich mit irgendwelchen
selbst signierten Zertifikaten,
und dann in den Store rein,
also in den Zertifikat-Store rein,
aber gut funktionieren tut es auf jeden Fall nicht.
Ähm...
Ja, also das ist der Witz, 12 Euro.
Was ist mit denen nicht richtig?
Du kriegst irgendwelche komischen YouTube
exclusive Serien,
wo ich noch nicht bei einer
bisher das Verlangen verspürt habe,
ähm,
die mir anzugucken.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was es da alles gibt,
aber alles, was mir bisher empfohlen wurde,
wollte ich definitiv nicht schauen
und geschweige denn 12 Euro im Monat dafür ausgeben.
Mir außerdem eine Sache, die mir auch extrem
auf den Sack geht bei der YouTube App ist,
jedes Mal, wenn du die YouTube App aufmachst,
wirst du gefragt,
ob du nicht
einen Monat kostenlos Trial machen willst.
Jedes Mal.
Und das geht mir so auf den Sack.
Ich will keinen Trial.
Jedes Mal muss ich sagen, nein, ich will keinen Trial.
Das ist,
das ist Lowbrain,
äh,
von Google, von YouTube,
von ABC, nee, von Alpha,
ach, wie auch immer wäre da jetzt, genau.
Über den Browser geht das nicht unter iOS.
Ja, das Schöne ist,
dieser Browser, den ich da entdeckt habe,
der so nach China Billig Browser aussieht,
du kannst sogar den, ähm,
User Agent ändern auf, äh,
andere Browser, dass der nicht mehr erkennt,
dass du, äh, dass du unter iOS unterwegs bist.
Sofern sie es am
User, äh, User Agent festmachen.
Play in Background.
Ich meine allein schon, dass es YouTube Music
gibt, die man nicht in Background spielen kann.
Hallo, das ist ein scheiß Player.
Die wollten ja, ich habe irgendwo mal gelesen,
dass Apple mit, äh, iOS 13
wollten die quasi so
halb zwangs einführen,
dass, ähm, alle Player über
das, über App, über, über die,
über die normalen iOS Schnittstellen playen müssen.
Und, ähm,
da haben, da haben sich wohl so viele App-Hersteller
beschwert, so nach dem Motto, was?
Da kann man ja auf einmal im Hintergrund abspielen,
da muss ja keiner mal unser Zeug gucken.
Dass sie dann gesagt haben, nee, machen wir doch nicht.
Tja, also,
kompletter, weiß ich, also, äh,
äh, muss nicht sein.
Muss, muss nicht sein.
So, dann, jetzt sind, jetzt sind genug Leute da,
jetzt können wir, jetzt können wir mal ein Spielchen spielen
und zwar spielen wir jetzt, ähm,
ja, ich weiß, auf, äh,
Herz 3.9, auf Android ist es kein Problem,
aber auf
iOS ist es ein Problem.
Wir spielen jetzt mal Rate die Programmiersprache.
Wir fangen mit was Einfachem an, ok?
Wir fangen mit was Einfachem an
und dann machen wir was richtig Schwieriges.
Äh, aber das, das ist, ich hab's vorhin mal kurz
ausprobiert und das ist ein randomizedes Quiz,
das heißt, das kenn ich auch nicht.
Das ist, das ist, das ist schwierig.
Das hier ist einfach. Das ist einfach.
Das ist einfach.
Ähm, seid, seid ihr schon,
seid ihr schon, äh, brain,
big brain genug heute Morgen, dass wir,
dass wir sowas machen können, ja?
Sind nur 20 Fragen oder so, ist nicht viel.
Schafft das euer Hirn heute Morgen schon?
Also Leute, was ist das für eine Sprache?
Wir haben zur Auswahl Swift,
Java, C-Sharp,
C++, was ist das?
Ha, der Chat kennt's wieder aus.
Jawoll, das ist C++, richtig.
Eindeutig. Allein schon da, äh,
daran erkennt man's. Ach, man kann...
Alter, low brain!
Leute, macht doch kein Source Code
als Bild.
Source Code als Bild, ja.
Das erinnert mich mal an, an eine Sache bei uns.
Irgendjemand bei uns
auf der Arbeit, ich sag jetzt den Namen nicht,
der fand es auch immer geil, in unser Ticketsystem,
äh, Screenshots
von irgendwelchen Excel-Tabellen reinzupasten,
wo ich mir dann einfach paste den Text rein,
und gut, ist... Ne, ging nicht.
So, alles C++, richtig.
Next.
Ähm, das da.
Wir haben zur Auswahl C-Sharp, Java,
JavaScript.
Was ist das hier?
Ey, man erkennt's, man erkennt's
ziemlich gut, ja.
Man kann sich, so von der groben
Struktur her kann man sagen, okay,
JavaScript ist es auf keinen Fall.
C-Sharp von der Struktur her
vielleicht, aber von den,
von den Klassenaufrufen und
den, äh, Namespaces
und, äh, von dem
Stringer her, von der kleinen, eher
nicht, also bleibt hier nur noch Java.
Ne? Bleibt
Java. Der Chat weiß Bescheid.
Next.
Ha!
Jetzt wird's schwieriger, wobei das auch noch relativ
offensichtlich ist. Was ist das?
JavaScript, C-Sharp, PHP oder Swift?
Also, wir können das, wir können das ja mal
ausschließen. Äh,
JavaScript. Ähm,
Function ist schon mal JavaScript,
aber diese ganzen Dollar-Geschichten
und hier Array,
Slice und Gedöns sieht nicht
nach JavaScript aus.
C-Sharp, so
kannst du in C-Sharp keine Funktion einlegen,
das passt von der Syntax ja hinten und vorne nicht.
Äh, Swift passt auch nicht,
aber PHP passt ganz gut.
Ja, PHP, richtig.
Also allein schon, allein schon
hieran erkennt man, dass es PHP ist, ja.
Impload, Array, Slice, das ist so typische
PHP Standard Library
Crap.
Ähm, okay, PHP.
Next.
Was denn? Das ist ein bisschen schwieriger schon.
Das ist ein bisschen schwieriger. Nicht so,
nicht so verbreitet, aber die Auswahl
macht's einfach. Die Auswahl
macht's einfach. Weil,
wenn wir mal anfangen, ist das, das könnte aus
Metroid sein, ja. 17.
Ah, doch.
Ja.
Metroid Prime.
Kotlin, richtig. Weil,
JavaScript kann's nicht sein.
Passt nicht von der Syntax her. C passt
von der Syntax her auch nicht. Bleibt bloß Kotlin. Also,
wenn die jetzt so ein paar andere Sachen
zur Auswahl reingebracht hätten, so
nach dem Motto, zum Vergleich
irgendwie Rust, Go,
keine Ahnung, irgendwie so, dann könnte man
vielleicht ein bisschen überlegen, aber hier ist ganz klar Kotlin.
Okay,
next. Das ist offensichtlich.
Undefined. So einen
Crap gibt's nur in einer Sprache.
Was ist es, Leute?
Ja, richtig.
Chat weiß Bescheid.
Also, JavaScript, was sonst?
Muss.
Muss. So was
kann doch JavaScript sein.
Object, Brototile, das ist eindeutig
JavaScript. Okay,
next. Was haben wir denn hier?
Das ist ein bisschen schwieriger.
Aber wenn man es mal verwendet hat, ist es auch
relativ offensichtlich, was es ist.
Fangen wir mal von unten an. Kotlin ist es auf keinen Fall.
Von der ganzen Syntax her
und vom Aufbau her. Scala
hat viel zu wenig Klammern.
Scala wäre
alles eine riesen Klammer.
Ruby passt die Syntax hinten und vorne
nicht. Bleibt nur Rust. Und ich weiß auch,
dass es Rust ist. Das ist Rust-Pattern-Matching.
Was halt in
und auch hier der Return-Typ mit dem
File und dem String und dem
Name, Doppelpunkt, Typ, das ist
eindeutig Rust.
So.
Ähm.
Ja.
Da wird's ein bisschen komplizierter,
aber es ist auch durch die
Auswahl relativ easy.
Ähm. F-Sharp
sonderlich funktional sieht das Ganze nicht aus.
Swift passt
von der Syntax her nicht.
Das heißt, es ist noch die Auswahl Ruby oder Pearl.
Für Pearl
ist es nicht kryptisch genug.
Und eine typische Sache bei Ruby
ist hier
diese Schleife.
B each x bla bla
a each print.
Und Funktionen hier ohne Klammern.
Das sieht typisch Ruby-mäßig aus.
Deswegen ist das Ruby.
Oder sagt ihr was anderes?
Aber das ist definitiv Ruby.
Warum?
Ruby ist eine tolle Sprache.
Huge. Big Brain.
Language.
Gibt es eigentlich noch Leute, die Ruby on Rails verwenden?
Das war ja mal
vor so
sagen wir mal 15 bis 10 Jahren
der heiße Shit, was
Webframeworks angeht.
Next. Okay.
Was ist das?
Das ist tatsächlich ein bisschen schwieriger.
Da sage ich jetzt mal
nix.
Durch die Auswahl ist es relativ
easy. Also eigentlich relativ
einfach.
Aber da sage ich mal nix. Was ist das?
Richtig. Swift.
Chat weiß Bescheid.
Das ist Swift.
Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen,
ich bin da auch nur drauf gekommen
durch Ausschlussverfahren.
Ich habe gesagt, C Sharp kann es nicht sein.
Java kann es nicht sein.
Und wie PHP sieht das Ganze auch nicht aus.
Deswegen bin ich auch nur auf Swift gekommen.
Und durch diese
Self-Geschichte.
Ich habe mal irgendwo gelesen,
dass sie in Swift anstatt This Self verwenden.
Aber es war Ausschlussverfahren
also Swift.
Richtig gewusst habe ich es auch nicht.
Okay.
Das ist einfach.
Es ist alt auf jeden Fall.
Also überlegen wir mal.
JavaScript.
Definitiv sieht es nicht aus wie JavaScript.
Sieht es aus wie Visual Basic?
Ne.
Sieht es auch nicht aus wie Visual Basic.
Kann ja nur FORTRAN sein.
So.
Das ist
eine der ehemaligen
Big Brain Languages.
Aber heute eher PP.
Next.
Ja.
Was ist das?
Da sage ich jetzt mal
auch nichts zu.
Durch das Ausschlussverfahren ist es eigentlich ziemlich einfach.
Assembly.
Genau.
Ja also.
Ich meine Assembler kann es
auf jeden Fall schon mal nicht sein.
Das sieht einfach überhaupt nicht nach
Assembler aus.
Das sieht nach deutlich höher als Assembler aus.
C kann es von der ganzen Syntax
her und wie das mit den Argumenten aufgebaut ist
kann eigentlich nur Go sein.
Es wäre viel interessanter gewesen, hätten sie es
ein bisschen schwieriger gemacht und hier irgendwie
noch Rust reingeschmissen, noch Javascript
reingeschmissen, irgendwas.
Aber das ist eindeutig Go.
Okay.
Ja.
Dank Ausschlussverfahren auch
relativ einfach.
Auch wenn man die Sprache nicht mehr wirklich verwendet.
Richtig Pascal.
Ruby kann es nicht sein.
Sieht überhaupt nicht aus wie Ruby.
Sieht auch überhaupt nicht aus wie PHP.
Ah das ist Dings hier.
Musik.
Ähm.
Was ist das nochmal? Kommt mir übelst bekannt vor.
Ah Soras Domain.
Genau. Okay also hier
Pascal. Eats.
Das ist jetzt tatsächlich
ein bisschen ausge- ausge-
gefallener, aber man kann es auch ganz gut
durch Ausschlussverfahren erkennen.
Ja. Also das ist Brainfuck.
Verwendet kein Mensch.
Verwendet kein Mensch, aber es ist offensichtlich
Brainfuck.
Nur für High
High End Brains geeignet.
Okay.
Das ist offensichtlich.
Das ist ein bisschen schwieriger.
Da kommen theoretisch mehrere
Kandidaten in Betracht, aber
es ist offensichtlich. Also so eklig
kann man das nur in einer
der dort genannten Sprachen machen.
Die einzige Write Only Sprache.
Richtig.
Paul.
Next.
Ähm. Hier
musste ich echt
überlegen.
Hier musste ich echt überlegen.
Was das ist.
Das ist schwierig. Also es ist
definitiv nicht XML und definitiv nicht
Brainfuck.
Da sind wir uns glaube ich einig.
Aber ist es Scala oder ist es PHP?
Nicht so einfach.
Ich hab's auch, ich hab's auch durch
Ausschlussverfahren gemacht.
Weil ich mir dachte, das ist
so quasi ähm
wie man hier Methoden Chained und so.
Sieht nicht nach PHP aus, aber
ich könnte jetzt auch nicht so pauschal
ausschließen, dass es PHP ist.
Deswegen würde ich sagen, es ist Scala.
Also ich weiß, dass es Scala ist, weil ich hab das ja
vorhin schon mal gemacht. Ähm.
Aber das ist schwieriger gewesen.
Aber der Hook weiß es.
Scala. Genau.
So. Ähm. Gut.
Das solltet ihr alle aus meinen Streams kennen.
Was ist das?
Ich würde sagen, das ist eindeutig eine INI Datei, oder?
Bash. Richtig.
Big Brain.
Ist ja CC Sharp, natürlich.
Was sonst? Zack.
So.
Nochmal für die äh
etwas älteren unter uns.
Es ist kein Assembler.
Es ist die Sprache, die nicht tot zu kriegen ist.
Es ist Cobol.
Genau.
Cobol.
Bisschen schwieriger.
Aber dank der Auswahl auch einfach.
Dank der Auswahl einfach.
Ähm.
Könnte schwierig sein. Hätte man da so was wie Scala,
und Erlang, und Gedöns,
und Haskell noch mit reingenommen,
dann wäre es schwierig gewesen.
Hainu Padrecht, das ist F Sharp.
Äh. Aber nachdem die einzige
funktionale Programmiersprache drin F Sharp ist,
muss das F Sharp sein.
Hätten wir hättens schwieriger machen können.
Aber das ist ja nur die Aufwärmrunde.
Das ist ja noch Eats.
Das andere, das hier, das ist richtig schwierig.
Ähm.
Next.
Äh.
Erkennt man, erkennt man auch, aber.
Hehehe.
Richtig.
It's a social basic.
Genau.
So. Was ist das?
Ist dank der Auswahl
Ausschlussverfahren auch einfach.
C++ kann sie nicht sein.
Sieht überhaupt nicht aus wie C++.
Wobei mich ehrlich gesagt nicht wundern würde,
wenn das nicht auch
gültige
C++ Syntax wäre.
In irgendeiner Art und Weise.
Ist alles irgendwie gültig, ja.
Aber es kann nicht C++ sein.
Ruby kann es auch nicht sein.
Und wie TypeScript sieht es auch nicht aus.
Also würde ich mal, habe ich hier mal auf Haskell getippt.
Ist es auch. So.
Letztes. Was ist das?
Das wisst ihr alle.
Vor allem bei dieser Auswahl dabei.
Fave. Ja. Richtig.
Bloß schon ewig keinen Cod mehr gespielt.
Also richtig.
Modern Warfare Beta und bisschen Release mal aus dem Vorgelassen.
Richtig.
Python.
Kennt sich aus hier.
Nice.
Ich hätt halt Ahnung.
So das war jetzt die Aufwärmrunde.
Das war jetzt easy.
Easy as fuck.
Das kann jeder. Jetzt wird's schwierig.
Jetzt kackt, bei dem anderen Quiz kack ich auch ab,
muss ich sagen.
Weil das ist randomized.
Das heißt ich hab jetzt keine Ahnung was kommt.
Das ist schwierig.
Zumal da 76 Programmiersprachen drin sind.
Und teilweise eine abgedrehter als die andere.
Okay. Play.
Was ist das?
Fuck, Alter.
Was?
Ich würd auch sagen
LOLcode.
Sieht irgendwie aus wie LOL.
Keine Ahnung. LOLcode.
Also Brainfuck ist es nicht.
Aber, aber
was ist Bifunge?
Also was soll ich nehmen? LOLcode oder Bifunge?
LOLcode, ne?
Wobei der High Noob kennt sich aus.
Der High Noob Sub. Der muss sich auskennen.
Also was soll ich nehmen?
LOLcode oder Bifunge?
Bifunge.
Komm. Bifunge. Wir nehmen Bifunge.
Bifunge. Bäm. Richtig.
Excellent.
Okay. Was ist das?
Das ist einfach.
Das ist Java. Muss Java sein.
Oder wie natürlich die coolen Leute sagen.
Java. Muss das sein. Java.
Äh.
Ach du Scheiße.
Ich hab nicht die leiseste Ahnung.
Wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Ich muss mal. Ich muss mal das Bild verschieben.
Das ist voll im.
Wir brauchen die Chat Power.
Brauchen wir.
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Also für Scala sind es nicht genug Klammern.
Prolog?
Für Erlang sind es auch
nicht genug Klammern. Das muss Prolog sein.
Ja. Geht's.
Wow. Es wird ja immer ekliger.
Log Talk?
Small Talk. Small Talk?
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Log Talk. Ich hab von der Sprache noch immer was gehört.
Was zum Teufel ist
Log Talk?
Ja. Small Talk und Scala sind
definitiv relativ weit.
Scala ist auf jeden Fall ziemlich weit verbreitet.
Small Talk nicht so wirklich.
Okay.
Small Talk? Okay.
Log Talk. Siehste.
Äh. Lumix hatte Recht.
Chat.
Chat hat's verkackt.
Das ist okay. Das ist wieder einfach.
Vor allem erstmal
Void-Sternchen-Message.
Alles Voidpointern.
Wobei mir nicht
bewusst ist, dass man in C
Putz verwenden kann.
Aber muss man.
Man kann ja auch Scan-Dings verwenden.
Aber
das müsste eigentlich C sein.
Voidpointer bin ich mir nicht sicher, wie es in C++
ausschaut. Ähm.
Das ist wahrscheinlich C.
So.
So. Alter.
Was soll das sein?
WTF.
Also Pascal ist es nicht.
C ist es auch nicht. Also bleibt bloß
äh. Bleibt bloß ECL.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was ECL ist.
Aber Ausschlussverfahren sagt mir, es ist ECL.
Ähm.
What?
Was?
Shakespeare?
Aha. Yes.
Shakespeare.
Das war klar.
To be or not to be.
Ah. Excellent. Excellent.
Shakespeare. Nein. Homespring.
Chat.
Alter.
Das kann man doch wissen.
Vertrau aus der Eier
in dem Chat, ey.
Okay. Next.
Object Hello World Extents App.
Klingt schon verdächtig.
Mal nicht nach Prolog.
Oder? Nee.
Ähm.
Ich.
Ich tippe mal auf Scala.
Aber ich.
Bei Scala hat es zu wenig Klammern.
Ähm. OCaml?
OCaml.
Wie spricht man das überhaupt aus?
Tja, Leute.
Ähm.
Beide Sprachen, in denen ich nicht viel Plan hab.
Ja.
Scala. Ich tendiere.
Ich tendiere auch, wenn es zu wenig Klammern hat.
Doch irgendwie zu Scala.
Ja.
Scala. Bam. Okay.
Okay. Das weiß ich jetzt.
Das weiß ich.
Was ist es?
AWK ist es. Jawohl.
Eindeutig.
Kein Perl.
Ist kein Perl, ist AWK.
Ähm.
Okay. Ruby ist es.
Nicht.
Fancy habe ich keine Ahnung.
Ich würde jetzt mal sagen Smalltalk.
Das ist Fancy.
Super Fancy. Aber brauchen wir bei Smalltalk Zeilen?
Ach, Moment.
Da sind keine Zeilennummern.
Das heißt, three times das da.
Das ist Fancy. Okay.
Wenn die Leute sagen, das ist Fancy, dann glaube ich euch.
Hey. Chat.
Huge.
Die wollen nicht ernsthaft wissen, was das für ein Dialekt ist, oder?
Sind die noch bei Sinn?
Keine Ahnung.
Geil.
Was weiß ich?
Keine Ahnung.
Also, das ist fies.
Das ist echt fies.
Ähm.
Okay.
Ich sag jetzt einfach mal.
Nein. Okay.
Smoker Smoke.
Putz.
Ich würde eigentlich sagen, das ist Ruby.
Weil genau so würdest du das in Ruby auch machen.
Aber Ruby ist nicht zur Auswahl.
Für Erlang hat es zu wenig Klammern.
Und für Lisp hat es definitiv zu wenig Klammern.
Also würde ich sagen, das ist TCL.
Ähm.
Ist das Heskel?
Idris?
Heskel kann es.
Das sieht zu wenig funktional aus.
Aber, wobei. Ich hab. Ey.
Mein Bauchgefühl sagt mir, es ist Heskel.
Aber sicher bin ich bin ich.
Es sieht ein bisschen funktional aus.
Aber, wobei.
Durch die Geschichte.
Dass du hier irgendwie sagst.
Die Funktion irgendwie.
Bauchgefühl würde ich sagen.
Heskel. Aber wissen tu ich es nicht.
Ah.
Fuck.
Der Hook hat recht. Idris.
Was zum Teufel ist Idris eigentlich für eine Sprache?
Hab ich.
Noch nie gehört.
Das ist Lick.
Okay. Next.
Ähm.
Function do it.
Disp. Hello.
Ich hab letztens mal nen.
Elixier Tutorial geguckt.
Ähm.
Und bilde mir ein.
Also Elixier.
Elixier sah ähnlich aus.
Die haben auch Def benutzt.
Ähm.
Aber der Rest sah.
Irgendwie anders aus.
Deswegen tendiere ich auch zu Matlab.
Ha.
Ein Leben noch Leute.
Ein Leben noch.
Ähm. Was haben wir denn hier?
Das. Ob.
Okay. Das ist definitiv schon mal kein C++.
Das ist auch kein Java.
Ne. Das ist kein C++.
Äh. Es ist Vala.
Würde ich sagen. Vala ist. Ähm.
Von GTK.
Diese. Diese.
Dieser C Sharp.
Java. C++.
Mischmasch.
Das müsste Vala sein.
Vala. Vala. Ich schwör.
Ne. Es ist. Es ist.
Es ist Vala.
Ziemlich sicher.
Ha. Erwischt. Oh je.
Okay. Go ist es nicht.
Ich.
Bauchgefühl sagt mir Smalltalk.
Aber was. Was sagt der Chat?
Smalltalk. Ja.
Smalltalk. Okay.
Smalltalk.
Ähm.
Ja.
Ja. Das ist definitiv kein C.
Das muss C Sharp sein.
Das sind wir uns einig. Ne.
Äh. Putz. Ruby.
Das ist Ruby.
Ähm. What?
Okay.
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Also Postscript.
Weiß ich nicht.
Ich mein Postscript ist
zum Drucken. Das kann schon Postscript sein.
Also Lisp
ist es nicht.
Lisp ist es nicht.
Kenn ich nicht.
Also ich tendiere zu Postscript.
Postscript ist das
was du deinem Drucker schickst zum Drucken.
Ich sag mal Postscript.
Ha. Eats.
Okay. Was haben wir jetzt als nächstes?
Foundation Punkt H.
Das ist Objective C.
Oder?
Ist das Objective C?
Weil NS Log.
NS klingt voll nach.
Objective C.
Als Objective C ist das.
Äh.
Das ist jetzt Elixier.
Das ist glaube ich jetzt Elixier.
Oder was sagt ihr?
Ich hab letztens ein Video da drüber geguckt.
Das ist glaube ich jetzt
Elixier. Ah yes.
Ha.
Och ne. Jetzt schon wieder.
Mensch. Komm. Hör mal auf mit dem
Scheiß. Äh.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich vertraue euch. Chat.
Ich schenke mir was zu trinken.
Zweimal Latex. Einmal
Kontext. Ja.
Was machen wir jetzt? Kontext.
Oh. Der Hook der hat vorhin schon mal richtig gelegen.
Außer ist er First
Time oder
Gründer Abo.
Ja.
Hast du eigentlich Frau und Kind? Nein.
Kontext. Okay. Ich glaub dir das jetzt mal.
Ha. Hui.
Print.
Okay. Go.
Also Go ist es nicht.
Genau.
Ich hab den Chat.
Ähm.
Also Go ist es nicht.
Java ist es auch nicht.
Es sieht nicht aus
wie Java. Also ist Gosu.
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Was zum Teufel.
Was Gosu für eine Sprache sein soll.
Ich sag einfach mal das ist Gosu.
Ja passt.
Ist das D?
Es ist nicht so wirklich C.
Es ist nicht so wirklich C-Sharp.
Also ist es D.
Ausschlussverfahren.
D ist irgendjemand der mal der Meinung war
er muss einen Nachfolger zu C++
oder einen C, C++ Nachfolger
bauen und hat es D genannt.
Geht das so lange bis man keine Lives mehr hat?
Ja. Ja. Es ist.
Okay. Ich stell ihm D.
Uh.
Also es sieht nicht aus wie Erlang.
Finde ich. Es sieht irgendwie nicht aus wie Erlang.
Es ist.
Es ist Forz.
Ich will auch sagen es ist Forz.
Ich hab Forz noch nie.
Forz Language.
1970.
Genauso sieht es aus.
Oh.
What the fuck.
Hello world. Cake with chocolate sauce.
Was?
Nicht Google.
Shakespeare Plainfuck oder Chef.
Okay das ist Chef.
Wer denkt sich sowas aus?
Brainfuck.
Leute.
Brainfuck oder? Sind wir uns einig?
Das muss Brainfuck sein.
Dart.
Dart. Es ist Dart.
Es kann kein Go sein.
Dafür stimmt die Funktionsdefinition nicht.
Es kann kein C sein. Dafür stimmt die Funktionsdefinition nicht.
Und die Funktion.
Das muss Dart sein.
It's.
Easy as fuck.
Wir hangeln uns hier ganz schön lange.
Mit einem Life lang.
Das ist.
Java.
Nee. Groovy?
Groovy. Groovy.
Chat. Give energy.
Ist das Groovy?
Echt. Java kann es nicht sein.
Da fehlen die Klammern um den Funktionsaufruf.
Es sieht überhaupt nicht aus wie Smalltalks.
Es muss Groovy sein.
Aha.
Alter.
Kombi nicht immer mit dem Scheiß.
Okay der Chat ist sich so einig.
Ich weiß nicht ob das Latte ist.
Bam. Jawoll.
Was ist das?
Es ist kein JavaScript.
Es.
Das könnte.
Durchaus.
Gültiges.
C sein was wir hier sehen.
Kommt auf den Rest drum herum an.
Dominik.
Wir erraten Programmiersprachen.
Man kriegt einen Ausschnitt aus dem Quelltext.
Und da muss man erraten was für eine Programmiersprache ist.
Gibt es Texte.
Text in C.
Ne aber das könnte eine Funktion sein.
Also je nachdem wie das Programm drum herum aussieht.
Könnte das durchaus gültiges C sein.
Aber ich tippe auch auf Processing.
Ich hab keine Ahnung was Processing ist.
Ja. Pokemon Song.
Ah. Gehts.
K. K. Stank Spy.
Hi.
Ken has standard IO.
Visible High World.
K. Stank Spy. Das ist LOL Code.
Das muss LOL Code sein.
Das klingt schon so nach LOL Code.
Yeah.
Pearl.
Right only. Pearl.
Äh.
Es muss Pascal sein.
Ist Pascal.
Fortran.
Ne Pascal kannst.
Ja.
Pascal. Ne Pascal wird der Kram groß geschrieben.
Ist das.
Fortran.
Ja. Nice.
Ähm.
Das ist ABAP.
Weil Kobol hat Zeilennummern.
Ich hab weder
ABAP noch Kobol jeweils
Programmiert. Nicht ABAP.
Nicht. Okay.
Ähm. Sondern.
Achso. Doch. Das ist ABAP.
Das müsste ABAP sein.
Nein. Nein.
Es ist doch Kobol.
Hat Kobol nicht Zeilennummern?
Grip. Grip.
Darf ich einen Link posten?
Kommt drauf an. Wohin?
Okay. Stats. Zeig mal. Zeig mal ob wir gut gewesen sind.
Nein.
Ich mein wohin der Link zeigt.
Darauf kommt es an.
7500.
Alter. Was geht mit den Leuten ab?
Wir hatten 3000.
Und wir sind schon Chat plus
mich.
Oh. Fuck. Alter.
Eieieiei.
Ne.
Das speicher ich mir mal.
Das können wir öfters machen.
Ich speicher mir das mal.
Können wir ab und zu mal machen.
Im Stream.
Dankeschön Kyokun.
Das wünschen wir dir auch.
Äh. Fast.
Auf eine Seite die dir zeigt wie man ohne
JavaScript IP Tracking jetzt die User footprinten kann.
Kannst du mal posten?
Ja.
Komm uns mal angucken.
So.
Say the Start Page.
So wir gucken uns jetzt mal ein nices Video an.
Das hab ich vor ner Weile schon mir angeschaut.
Und fand ich richtig gut gemacht.
Ähm.
Geht halt. 47 Minuten.
Geht um irgendwelche Speed.
Aha. Interessant.
He.
Das ist interessant. Okay.
Ist wirklich JavaScript blocken bringt nix.
Sehr interessant. Ja.
Hehehe.
Die machen gar nichts oder?
Die machen wahrscheinlich das anhand meiner
auf dem Server irgendwie fest oder so, ne?
Das ist wahrscheinlich gar nichts Kleinseitiges.
Das ist hardcoded, oder?
Das ist einfach
hardcoded.
Das ist, äh, G-Bait.
Ja, entweder ist das
bei IP oder bei, oder
na, hardcoded ist es schon mal nicht.
Der Link scheint nicht so, scheint nicht,
nicht gut. Das muss irgendeine Geschichte
sein, äh, was die anhand vom Request
festmachen.
Das ist aber gut gemacht.
Aha, okay, das ist, das ist aber gut.
Ja.
Es gibt so unglaublich viele Varianten mittlerweile, User
zu tracken. Aber es ist gut.
Huge Brain.
Okay, jetzt gucken wir uns mal das Video zu,
ups, nein, äh, äh,
das Video zu den Mario Kart
Rekorden an.
Alter.
Ich abgratze jetzt.
Is it impossible
to upload
a mathematically impossible
level in Mario Maker?
Das interessiert mich jetzt, das müssen wir jetzt gucken.
Okay.
Das müssen wir jetzt gucken.
Mal gucken, mal gucken, ich mein, ich spiel zwar
kein Mario Maker, aber das klingt
nach, nach Huge Brain Content.
Okay.
So about two weeks ago, I thought it would be
fun to theorycraft the strongest
and most secure combination
log possible in Super Mario Maker 2.
There never really was a point to this
in the first Mario Maker, since everyone
was able to download each course and therefore
everyone was able to take a look at the combination.
But since Nintendo, sadly,
decided that editing downloaded
courses is no longer a thing in Mario Maker 2,
that also means that, at least in theory,
it should be possible to upload a combination
log stage that is so secure that it becomes
cryptographically...
Ah, yes, alles klar, Leute.
Ah.
I sat down and naively started to
scribble together a couple of different designs
for logs, not knowing what I just did.
So, over the last two weeks, I spent way, way,
way, way, way, way, way, way, way, way, way, way, way, way, way, way, way, way, way, way, way, way, way, way.
Way too much time trying to come up with
the absolute perfect combination log in Super Mario Maker 2.
It honestly almost drove me insane.
So today we're going to take a look back at this journey.
We will not only succeed in building a log
that is mathematically impossible to beat,
but we will also fail miserably at trying to upload
a truly impossible stage.
So, are you ready?
Let's do this.
Ich check zwar überhaupt nicht, warum und weshalb, aber weil es geht, denke ich.
Einfach nur, weil es möglich ist.
So before we hop into Mario Maker and try to theorycraft the perfect log,
we first quickly have to talk about how combination logs function in the first place.
So, how do logs work?
The probably easiest way to think of the safety of a combination log
is to assume that each log has a certain numerical safety.
That's how many different combinations it has, obviously.
The interesting thing here is that this number is defined by two things.
The base of the log and its length.
A standard bicycle log, for example, often contains...
Ja gut, ist ja bei Passwörtern ähnlich.
between zero to nine.
So each spot in the log is one out of ten different numbers.
Was redet er?
We're going to call this number...
Der redet so big brain language, dass es einfach normale Leute wie wir nicht verstehen.
Also, gebt dir gar keine Mühe.
The base of the log, the length of the log is...
Also, was der uns gerade, glaube ich, versucht zu erklären ist, was ein...
ähm...
Schloss sichermacht, beziehungsweise was eine Schlüsselkombination sichermacht.
Und das erste ist natürlich, wie viele Varianten du hast.
Also beim Passwort, wie viele Varianten du hast, also wie viele verschiedene Zeichen du hast.
Und dann, wie lang das Ganze ist.
Ist im Prinzip bei einem Schloss ja das gleiche.
Genau.
Base ist im Prinzip, was du für...
Base ist, was du für verschiedene...
Zeichen hast.
Ja, also in dem Fall hast du bei einem normalen Schloss, wo du so Drehrädchen dran hast, null
bis neun, hast du null bis neun, also zehn verschiedene mögliche Zeichen pro Stelle.
Und das Ganze ist vier Stellen lang.
Das ist so ein Standardschloss, was beispielsweise an so einem, so einem Koffer oder, oder, oder
so, oder so kleines Zahlenschloss.
Das heißt, du hast zehntausend Varianten.
Die man durchprobieren muss.
Das ist nicht viel.
Allerdings von Hand durchzuprobieren.
Hand durchzuprobieren dauert ein bisschen.
Passwortmäßig ist es...
Er baut ein Zahlenschloss in Mario Maker.
Ich glaube, das hat er vor.
Er möchte einen Schloss in Mario Maker bauen, wo nur er die Kombination kann.
Und es so unwahrscheinlich ist, dass man es errät, dass man das Level nicht lösen kann.
Also, huge brain.
Have I screwimm...
That vector into a locks strand, is much much more important than the other one.
The land of the lock make it way more secure than it´s base value.
Yeah.
Das ist beim Passwort dann übrigens auch so, ne.
Und wir baru dari pont dabei sind ist das bei Passord dann auch so.
Das ist bei Pass recruiting ist doch so...
Das der wichtigste ist eigentlich, dass das Passlar als zwei 2011 ist, weg greed ICA3
und das so viel Webseiten immer noch immer noch quasi.
Erzwingen.
Das da ein Sonderzeichen, groß und klein, schreibe und ne Zahl und sowas.
Dann macht der Passen Register Town no two so, weil der Target, der Zeit da ist, hat er
auch nicht nach dazu von, 당 1967 Dacioliク und der Standard.
Groß- und Kleinschreibung und eine Zahl und sowas
drin sein muss, man sollte einfach sagen
ab einer gewissen Länge ist alles erlaubt, weil
es ist einfach easy zu merken
wenn man jetzt ein Passwort macht, so nach dem Motto
nach dem Motto
mein cute
Chat Twitch ist beste
das ist so ein langes Passwort
da kommt keine Sau drauf
und das kannst du auch nicht einfach mal so ausprobieren
auch wenn es normale Wörter sind
ja
und das ist
dann schon ziemlich
sicher, wohingegen wenn ich jetzt
gezwungen werde, da Sonderzeichen rein zu machen
und Zahlen
und sonst was, dann kann ich
mir den Kramer nicht mehr merken
cute Chat
ja meine Null
das ist relativ einfach auszurechnen
vor allem wenn du 0 bis 10 an Zeichen hast
dann hängst du einfach das da in Nullen hinten dran
und gut ist
guck, bam
mach doch als Leerzeichen
ein Dollar, kannst du machen, ja
wenn du dir das merken kannst
ja, das stimmt
das stimmt, ist mal passbar, dann genau so
was klappt
war nicht gut
dass wir den
noch klar
was
Glocken
in
週
kann
der Land
werden
und wir als
Also ich will jetzt nicht hier vorgeben, dass ich verstehe, was da gerade passiert,
aber ich finde es trotzdem interessant, was er macht.
Weil ich habe keine Ahnung von den Mario Maker Mechanics.
Ah, Big Brain.
Let's focus on the base and its length.
See, when building this log, I made a really stupid mistake.
I focused on building a log in our lame, standard and boring decimal numerical base 10 system.
Well, there is absolutely no reason to do so in the Mushroom Kingdom.
There is no benefit if a log has a base of 10.
All it does is heavily limiting us with the entity limit.
What we need is a much more creative way to represent the log.
Think about the lottery as an example.
A standard lottery often wants us to guess...
Alles klar!
...between 0 and 47.
There's nothing else than trying to brute force a combination log base 48 with a length of 6.
They just make the base really high so that it becomes counterintuitive how many different options a lottery log actually has.
For a perfect Mario Maker log...
Ja, Mathe Clue, das stimmt.
50 hoch 6 ist eine deutlich kleinere Zahl als 26 hoch 16.
...we should try to minimize...
...how many different entities...
...we need per log cell...
...and focus on getting the log as long as possible within the 100 entity limit.
So the first idea I had was just to build a really long log using binary numbers.
Binary means that each log cell only has exactly two inputs.
Either no question block didn't get triggered or triggering the question block it was.
If we found a way to just combine 40 of such cells into a single log...
...then we would already have more than 1 trillion different combinations...
...while each additional cell would grow this number exponentially.
Hooray.
So here's the first prototype.
Each question block here represents a single digit and has two sides.
Triggered and not triggered.
If you trigger a question block, the blaster jumps upwards.
The blasters have two different height levels.
The idea here is that we only get a flat surface at the top if all blasters are at the correct spot.
If a blaster that needs to get triggered doesn't get triggered...
...then we only get a flat surface at the top if all blasters are at the correct spot.
If a blaster that should not get triggered gets triggered however...
...then this blaster is one spot too high.
Super simple stuff.
Super simple? Easy!
Also Leute, Leute, super simple, oder?
Easy as fuck!
Kann man echt nix sagen.
Also wer da noch Fragen hat, der sollte uninstallen.
...a log that slowly transports a cannon to an enemy at the far left...
...only if the top is a straight line...
...and therefore all inputs were entered correctly...
...the cannon reaches the enemy, crushes it...
...and rewards us with a key in the process.
Hooray!
Sadly, this design has several problems.
First, we have to put the blasters onto global ground...
...because otherwise they despawn while we enter the combination.
Second, we also have to put global ground at the top...
...so that the cannon does not despawn while the log gets red...
...since icicles aren't global ground anymore.
We no longer have a global ground option that does not count towards the enemy limit...
...so we can only build this log with a length of a bit over 40...
...that's slightly better than our previous design, but still pretty meh.
Luckily, I just lied to you when I said that there are no more global ground options...
...that do not count towards the entity limit.
Ich hab keine Ahnung was passiert.
There is still something in the game that counts towards the block limit...
...while also being global ground.
Something super weird.
Cloud blocks in the 3D world style.
Yep, I know that this is super weird...
...but normal cloud blocks in 3D world act as global ground.
This means that if we build a log like this in 3D world...
...we do not have to use platforms and tracks as global ground anymore.
Here's what such a log looks like.
This log has a length of 64 at the base of 2.
This means that this super simple log is able to store about 18 quintillion numbers.
18 quintillions are a billion numbers.
18 quintillions are a billion...
...billions.
That's why the secure log that we got there.
Sadly, it doesn't really work for several reasons.
First, the springs that we spawn to get the blasters upwards...
...unfortunately also land on global ground.
Which means that we fill the ELB at some point...
Leute, ich hab keine Ahnung was passiert.
Ich blicke nicht mehr durch, aber...
...die steht trotzdem da.
...point during the input and no springs can spawn no more.
Second, the snake block that we use to read the state of the log...
...sadly destroys all the blasters that are set too high when reading the log.
Meaning it's...
...well...
...it um...
...it just tells us the exact combination.
Whoops, so we need to find a better way to input numbers...
...as well as we need to find a better way to read the state of the log.
So, the best and chiefest way to read the log...
...is just to have mario escort an enemy to the other side.
That's not the problem.
The real problem...
...is how to do the inputs in such a way...
...that we do not require global ground...
...or any other additional entities.
And this ladies and gentlemen...
...is where stuff gets a bit insane.
So, um...
...as it turns out we can ignore global ground entirely...
...if we use spawn blocking and an escort version to read the log.
Check this out.
Here we input our code...
...by breaking the brick blocks at the bottom.
Each broken brick block...
...means we entered a 1...
...into our log...
No, this video is new.
This is new.
This is from...
...13.
...from brick block...
...reported to 0.
...or another new one.
...at the top we have red dotted line blocks.
And here's the catch.
Those red dotted line blocks...
...spawn block bullet blasters.
Bullet blasters can't spawn...
...while there is a red block occupying their home space.
But as soon as a two-state block gets flipped...
...they are suddenly able to spawn again.
It's the same as before.
Each blaster...
...as well as...
Yeah, Nitro Express.
10.000 Kombination is too low.
...is the correct combination...
...for it's a bled surface...
...for an enemy...
We need 75 billion.
Trillion.
...and our input either makes the enemy fall down...
...or blocks the path forward entirely.
Monster of Jelly.
...only requires a single enemy...
...that carries a key...
...and a single blaster per log cell...
...since we can put the on-off block into a different subworld.
This block can be built with a length of 99.
The only entity space that isn't used...
...to lock cells...
Isn't used.
Lock cell...
Isn't used to an Cel Essen...
...for Log Cell...
...indeed...
...it is essential.
...for historical software...
Identify Synchen...
...right.
... MEGANETIC MEGANETIC 2.
...al accommodated.
...dreibend...
you need to go debug the area...
...for used cert...
...since you...
...dreibend...
...eeeee small screen...
...it has a medium size of 97 CC.
You need to make sure you...
...that every cell is mostly...
...inhabitable in TC.
...the subject of the pledge argument...
...and the file to bind up...
...the server of communication is fixed.
It should always pass.
...it den user should...
All other 99 entity spots are used for the lock.
This gives us a base 2 length 99 lock.
That's a lock that has 633 billion different states.
That's 633 billion, billions, billions different combinations.
That's a lock that can't get brute-forced anymore.
So the length of this lock is pretty much optimal.
The only possible improvement would be to find a way to build a lock without normal entity limit items,
which sadly appears to be impossible.
But we aren't done here yet.
Because while it isn't possible to improve the length of the lock anymore,
it is actually possible to improve its base value.
See, since we are now working with spawn blocking, there is no reason for us to build this in binary.
We can actually use many brick blocks per cell as a way of inputting a number.
Since the lock needs to remain invisible for Mario while it gets read,
the maximum height of brick blocks is 8.
8 brick blocks gives us a base 9, since 0 is also an input option.
Here's how this works.
There is only one way for the blaster to be at exactly the correct height,
and that is when the correct amount of brick blocks got destroyed before.
This blaster, for example, only spawns if 7 blocks got destroyed.
If a number smaller than 7 is entered into the lock,
then there is always a brick block.
This block remains and prevents the blaster from spawning.
If the number 8 is entered,
the blaster crops down one tile too much.
So this gives us a lock that requires us to input 99 times a correct number between 0 and 8.
And there is definitely only one correct command.
In this case, there is only one correct command that actually rewards the blaster with a key at the end.
So this lock is a lock base 9, length 99.
This lock has 29 trigon-tillion different input options.
That's a number with 95 decimal digits.
Here's the exact number.
Ah, yes.
So muss das sein.
It is completely impossible, in a cryptographical sense, that someone guesses this number back.
Let's just quickly do a small font experiment, so that all of you get a feeling of why I'm so sure that this lock can't get guessed.
Right now, Mario Maker 2 sold about 4 million copies.
Let's say every single person that bought Mario Maker up until now, besides to dedicate their entire life from now on,
trying to crack a code, each person enters about 1000 combinations each time.
Theoretisch möglich, aber sehr unwahrscheinlich.
Ich hab nicht mal Mario Maker 2, ich kann das nicht mal ausprobieren.
Ja gut, diese Sachen kann man ja auch auf Passwörter anwenden, wo dann so Rechnungen rauskommen, so irgendwie...
Wenn alle Rechner der Welt 24 Stunden bla bla bla irgendwie rechnen würden, dann wären die nicht fertig vorm Ende des Universums, so nach dem Motto.
Das ist halt voll übertrieben.
Die Zahl ist definitiv groß genug, dass sie nicht einfach erraten wird.
Es gibt also 416 Millionen einzelne Inputs pro Tag,
und 1 Trillion und 460 Billionen einzelne Inputs pro Jahr.
Also, wenn wir die Anzahl der Kraft des Logs mit diesem Nr. verteilen,
dann sollten wir wissen, wie viele Jahre es dauert,
bis jede Kombination einmal eingebunden wurde,
assuming dass 4 Millionen Leute
jeden Tag 1000 Mal versucht haben.
So die Antwort ist
um die 26 Billionen Jahre,
das ist ein Nr mit 82 Zigarren.
das ist um die 26 Billionen Jahre,
das ist ein Nr. mit 82 Zigarren.
Man kann doch garantiert Mario Maker Level runterladen und dann sich irgendwie auf einer
SD-Karte oder so angucken. Irgendwie so ein Mario Maker Level Decompiler oder so. Gibt es doch 100 Pro schon.
Ja, Moment, Herz 93, es geht offiziell nicht. Nicht in Mario Maker, aber es gibt doch bestimmt
irgendeine Möglichkeit, Mario Maker Level runterzuladen.
WTF, die Leute, Alter.
Ja, Moment, Herz 93, es geht offiziell nicht.
Also, lasst mich euch eine kleine Geschichte mit euch erzählen.
Also, ein paar Wochen vor, hat ein US-Gamer-Journalist mir ein kurzes Mail gesagt, dass er mir dachte,
eine kurze Geschichte über Passcode-Levels in Super Mario Maker 2 zu schreiben und ob
ich ihm ein paar Fragen beantworten würde.
Und ich war so, ja, warum nicht.
Und dann?
Dann habe ich angefangen zu wundern, was eigentlich der sicherste Kombination-Log ist.
Also habe ich mich gesetzt und angefangen, mit dem zu denken und das ist das, was dieses
ganze Wahnsinn kostet.
Also habe ich unseren US-Gamer-Journalisten eine Weile zurückgekommen und als er
antwortete, war ich tatsächlich alle, die das gemacht haben.
Also, hier ist, wo es interessant wird, weil die erste Frage, die er mir gefragt hat,
war etwas in der Linie, ob du denkst, dass V-Drags Passcode-Level optimal designt ist
oder ob du denkst, dass sein Design immer noch verbessert werden kann.
Und ich war so, welches V-Drag-Design wieder?
Also, ähm, wie es scheint, war ich nicht der Einzige, der viel zu viel Zeit mit meinem
Leben verpasst hat, um ein unnötiges Niveau so hoch wie möglich zu bekommen, weil, wie
es scheint, der legendäre Mario Maker 2.
Creator V-Drag was working on this as well.
And as it turns out, he found a way to build a combination lock that is much, much, much
more secure than the design we just feel re-cropted.
So, I'm not going to spoil how he did it, because he made an amazing and really entertaining
video on how it works that pretty much continues at exactly the point where this video ends.
I honestly can't recommend you more than this and it's good enough.
It's a really fun, quick watch and, well...
And his combination lock, it's our combination lock for breakfast.
The link is in the description.
So, with that being said, thanks for watching this little video.
I hope you enjoyed it.
If you enjoyed it, don't forget to leave me a thumbs up and maybe feel especially
a combination lock.
Ah, WTF.
I hope that all of you have a wonderful day and to see you soon.
Goodbye.
WTF, ey.
Das ist ja hart.
Aber, wo man wieder schön dran sieht, sobald was geht.
Sobald was geht.
Sobald was bleibt, wird's gemacht.
Eigentlich könnte man Mario Maker schon in diese Liste aufnehmen.
So nach dem Motto, errate die Programmiersprache.
Heftig.
Graser Shit.
ETF.
Oh man.
Wie lange sind wir eigentlich schon on?
Leute, ich muss mal aufs Klo.
Ich muss mal aufs Klo.
Ich bin gleich wieder da.
Ich bin gleich wieder am Start.
Wasaffk.
So, wieder am Start.
Leute, was gab es bei euch gestern eigentlich zu essen?
Hühnerrouladen mit Bacon.
Wildschwein, okay.
Gans.
Ja, ich habe bei vielen Leuten gelesen, dass Gans bzw. Ente gegeben hat.
Würstchen mit Kartoffelsalat.
Ja, das waren auch viele.
Reh.
Ja, bei uns gab es die letzten Jahre an Weihnachten auch immer Reh.
Oder Hirsch.
Wild.
Äh, aber bei uns gab es gestern Abend Burger.
So richtig klassisch Weihnachtsessen, ja.
Erst mal Burger bestellt.
Habt ihr übrigens gesehen, dass die Black Mesa Xen Levels rausgekommen sind gestern oder vorgestern?
Das heißt, dass müssen wir definitiv im Stream spielen.
MW2, oh, das ist ja ewig her.
Bei uns gab es auch Burger.
Burger.
Oh je.
Monka Torsal.
Roastbeef mit Kroketten, Spargel und Bohnen.
Ah, auch nicht schlecht, ja.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob wir jetzt ein 47 Minuten Mario Kart Video angucken wollen.
Ich fand das Video ist echt gut gemacht.
Ich meine, 2,7 Millionen Views und 94K, geil, aber das ist ein bisschen lang alles, ne.
Was empfiehlt uns denn YouTube noch so?
Mac vs. PC Video Editing mit IGELINE.
Der Auer übertaktet wieder irgendwas kaputt.
Floppen Googles Gaming Pläne.
Naja, das ist ja einen Monat her.
Das ist ja, das habe ich, dass Google, Googles Gaming Pläne floppen, das habe ich seit Ankündigung prediktet, ja.
Es kann sein, dass ich komplett daneben liege, aber ich glaube, wir werden Stadia demnächst so in, nicht nächstes Jahr, auch nicht übernächstes Jahr, aber.
Dann demnächst hier irgendwo sehen.
Weil es ist doch schon erstaunlich still drum geworden für das, dass das die Zukunft des Gaming sein soll, oder?
So ein halbgares Google-Ding wieder.
Wisst ihr, wo ich echt, wo ich eigentlich am gespanntesten drauf bin bei Stadia?
Nicht so sehr, ob es jetzt fällt oder nicht, sondern wenn es failen sollte, was mit den Spielen passiert.
Die für Stadia exklusiv.
Rausgekommen sind, weil das wäre dann quasi so das erste größere Ereignis, wo quasi Spiele massenhaft unwiederbringlich verloren sind.
Sollten sie nicht anderweitig erscheinen.
Negative Latenz, ja, so ein dummes Gelaber immer, äh.
Es will einfach auch niemand haben.
Ja, ich weiß auch nicht, was mit den Google-Leuten los ist.
Äh, nee, äh, Wasser, Wasserfreak.
Angular ist nicht RIP, dass er, Angular 1 ist RIP.
Das, das, das andere ist immer noch am Start.
Aber.
Man sieht mal, wie viel, ne?
Wie viele Google-Dienste es schon gegeben hat.
Und wisst ihr, was der Google-Dienst ist, dem ich, dem ich am wenigsten nachweine?
Wo steht's denn?
Warum steht denn das da nicht drin?
Das gibt's auch nicht mehr.
Ah, da.
Ja.
Bam.
Der Sache weine ich definitiv nicht nach.
Der Google-Urschortner, da verstehe ich nicht, warum sie den jemals abgeschaltet haben.
Ich meine, so ein Urschortner, es kann jetzt ja nicht sein, dass so ein Urschortner irgendwie unglaublich wahnsinnige, äh, Ressourcen frisst.
Und ich fand es eigentlich ganz praktisch, dass Google auch einen Urschortner angeboten hat.
Da habe ich, den habe ich früher sogar immer verwendet.
Ich weiß nicht, warum man einen Urschortner-Dienst überhaupt abschaltet.
Der Sache weine ich ja echt keine Träne nach.
Die haben, Google Plus war quasi single-handed, so, so, so einzig und alleine mit dafür, also zum größten Teil zumindest, mit für verantwortlich, dass das Kommentarsystem auf YouTube so scheiße ist, wie es heute ist.
Weil das da einfach reinhängt.
Weil das da einfach reingeprügelt wurde, ohne Sinn und Verstand.
Warum er Video-Annotations rausgemacht hat, finde ich auch ein bisschen kacke.
Aber es gibt, wie ihr seht, es gibt echt so viel Zeug.
Kann man das sortieren?
Nach, ach, das ist nach Datum sortiert, ne?
Ja, das geht auch nicht mehr, dass man direkt Webseiten übersetzt.
Das meiste Zeug davon kenne ich gar nicht.
Könnte auch heißen, killed by Firma XY.
Naja, in dem Fall sind es halt alles Google-Projekte.
Google sind nicht die einzigen, die sowas machen.
Was war denn, das, war Datum nicht so eine, so eine Bildschirmschoner-Geschichte?
Ne, das kenne ich alles gar nicht mehr.
Ja, YouTube-Messages war schon der, das schlechte YouTube-Message-System.
Es gibt übrigens immer noch einen Trick.
Also es gibt genug Add-ons, mit denen man das machen kann.
Mit Webseiten übersetzen.
Geht immer noch.
Bloß halt nicht mal direkt über Google.
Warum auch immer man das abschaltet.
Oh!
Oh, hier haben sie sich sehr in die, in die, in die Brennnesseln gesetzt, ja.
Ähm, es haben ganz viele Leute im Heimautomatisierungsbereich, haben sich vor Jahren Nestgeräte, wo, als sie noch nicht Google waren, Nestgeräte gekauft, weil es ein Hersteller war, der, der quasi ganz guten API-Zugriff angeboten hat.
So, dass man quasi seine Thermostate in seine Heimautomatisierung integrieren konnte.
Und Google hat das dann gekauft und Google hat gesagt, nope, die API, die machen wir nicht.
Machen wir nicht.
Aber überlegen, fünf Jahre, ne?
Also die Leute haben sich ja wirklich drauf verlassen.
Von heute auf morgen geht ihnen Scheiß nicht mehr.
Dann, sie haben so ein bisschen zurückgerudert.
Und dann sagt, ja, bloß Neuregistrierung.
Was aber im Prinzip aufs Gleiche rauskommt.
Ja, es ist, es ist dead.
Project Ara, weiß ich gar nicht mehr, was das ist, was das war.
War das, ah, doch, doch, ich weiß es, ich weiß es.
War das, ne, ne, ne, Moment, das war, das war, das war die 3D-Brille.
Ähm, was war Project Ara nochmal?
Sag, sag mir.
Nichts mehr.
Ach, das, war das das Smartphone?
Ah, das habe ich nur so am Rande mitgekriegt.
Ach, YouTube Gaming gibt es nicht mehr.
Moment, YouTube Gaming gibt es nicht mehr?
Okay.
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Was ist an YouTube?
Ich meine, Top Livestreams, 525, das ist, okay, 15K.
Das ist noch nicht mal, das ist irgendwie noch nicht mal richtig sortiert.
Ganz, ganz merkwürdig.
Also damit bin ich, damit bin ich nie warm geworden.
Und was ich bei Google Gaming auch merkwürdig fand,
dass es so gemischt war aus Video und Live-Inhalten,
dass du nie genau wusstest, es ist jetzt live, es ist jetzt ein Video.
Komisch.
Gibt es noch YouTube Kids?
Ja, da wird laufend Werbung für gemacht.
Was, Aero?
In Bangalore, Mumbai, Delhi, gut, okay, also, also alles, äh, in der Nähe.
Google Plus, ah, zum Glück ist es weg, dieser Kack.
Ich hasse Google Plus.
Was hat das, das hat das Message-System auf YouTube so kaputt gemacht?
Chromecast ist weg, ah ne, Chromecast Audio.
Okay.
Es gibt so viel Zeug, von dem ich noch nie was gehört hab.
Google News, was, Google News?
Es gibt, es gibt kein Google News mehr?
Oder ist das, das war eine irgendwie extra App, oh.
Tets, habe ich noch nie gehört.
Google Plus war eine Bombe, zwar weg, aber hat Schäden hinterlassen, oh ja.
Wie viel Zeug die hatten.
Der Video Editor, das ist auch so ein Ding.
Der war an sich, also wenn man davon ausgeht, dass jeder seine Videos perfekt macht vor dem Upload, war der überflüssig.
Aber manchmal war der Video Editor ganz praktisch.
Ich habe es beispielsweise mal geschafft, in irgendeinem Unboxing meine Adresse zu leaken.
Also habe ich den YouTube Video Editor genommen.
Und das waren halt noch Zeiten, wo es halt nicht so easy war, einfach mal drei Gigabyte neu hochzuladen.
Mittlerweile ist es kein Ding.
Da habe ich den YouTube Video Editor genommen und habe einfach das kurz entfernt und neu rendern lassen auf YouTube.
Ging relativ schnell im Vergleich zum Re-Upload.
Deswegen verstehe ich nicht sogar, warum muss man so Sachen rausnehmen.
Die braucht man zwar nicht immer, aber die sind halt schon sehr praktisch, wenn man sie braucht.
Wie lange dauert denn so ein 3 Gigabyte Upload?
Boah, keine Ahnung, 25 Minuten oder so, ich weiß es gar nicht.
Ich muss mal mal ausrechnen.
Also ich habe 400 MB Upload, müssen wir mal ausrechnen.
Okay, der Upload Rechner, ich rechne mal aus.
Ich brauche, ich brauche für...
400 Down, 40 Up.
26 Minuten brauche ich für 8G.
Also sprich für 3, für 3 Gigabyte brauche ich 10 Minuten.
Ungefähr.
Sind das hohe Kosten?
Es geht.
Es ist billiger als vorher.
Vorher war ich ja so bescheuert und hatte den Telekom Anschluss plus den Unity Media Anschluss.
Mittlerweile habe ich nur noch Unity Media.
Vollwertiges IPv6 und vollwertiges IPv4.
Also ein richtig echter Dual Stack.
Es kostet, ich weiß nicht genau, was es kostet im Monat, aber es ist nicht super billig.
Ich glaube irgendwie 68 Euro oder so.
Mit Power Upload 70 Euro, irgendwie sowas.
Aber immer noch deutlich günstiger, als noch einen Telekom Anschluss dazu zu haben.
Ich habe es jetzt ja so.
Ich habe mein Telefon, also mein Festnetz Telefonnummer habe ich portiert.
Zu einem reinen VoIP Anbieter, das kostet 2 Euro im Monat.
Dann ist sie einfach mal da und weg und sicher.
Telekom weg und Unity Media für Internet.
Ja, Herz390, du könntest dir Power Upload holen.
Die Frage, ob sich das lohnt.
Bei mir ist es natürlich ganz gut, weil ich Videos hochlade.
Das geht dann schön schnell.
Und mit 40 Mbit, Leute, theoretisch, könnte ich mit 40 Mbit auch irgendwie ein paar kleine Sachen daheim hosten.
Ja, ich könnte beispielsweise einen Raspberry hinter meinen Router stöpseln.
Und was ist Power Upload?
Das ist eine Option, die man bei Unity Media ankreuzen kann für doppelten Upload Speed, wenn es unterstützt.
Die Power Upload heißt, ich meine, die Leitung gibt es auch so her.
Oh, Glasphase, Ende Gelände, das ist natürlich nice.
40 Downs, äh, 400 Downs, 200 Up.
Also, Unity Media, du kannst hier irgendwo...
Ne, 400 Up nicht.
400 Up, ne, ne, ne, 40 Up habe ich.
40.
400 Down, 40 Up.
Naja, Unity Media ist die einzige Alternative zur Telekom, weil die Telekom sagt, also, äh, ja, bei mir schon.
Vielleicht habe ich auch aus Versehen gesagt, 400 Down.
Äh, 400 Up, aber es sind 400 Down und 40 Up.
Das gibt es leider, leider bei uns nicht, 1000.
Was ich halt echt nervig finde, dass die einem laufen, die irgend so einen Crap versuchen mit in den Warenkorb zu schmeißen, wenn man was einkauft, ja.
Guck mal, deutsche Glasfaser.
Ausbau.
Hanau.
Bayern.
Hessen.
Guck mal mal.
Ne, bei uns nicht.
Naja.
Also, ich kann mit 40...
Ab 400 Down erstmal leben.
Das ist okay.
Ey, guck mal, da ist es, ja.
Hab mal gehört, die NASA soll über einen Gigabit abhaben.
Naja, die NASA hat garantiert mehr.
Wir auf der Arbeit haben schon...
Wir hatten, wir hatten die letzten Jahre immer 2 Gigabit und ich glaube mittlerweile haben wir 10 Gigabit ab.
Das ist kein Ding.
Kann man haben, ja.
Legales Viewbotting.
Ich will überhaupt keine Viewbots.
Viewbots sind nicht im Chat aktiv.
Viewbo...
Viewbots subscriben nicht.
Totaler Crap.
Wer meint mit Viewbots irgendwas zu reißen, der hat es ja nicht mal alle.
Die Videoempfehlungen sind heute nicht so dolle.
What?
Moment.
Warte mal, warte mal.
Jetzt bald mal ein größeres Softwareprojekt, welches du streamst.
Ich bin ja immer noch an meiner Video-Streaming-Geschichte dran.
Ich will eigentlich nur hören, wie sich es anhört am Ende.
Tatsächlich.
Es funktioniert.
Wusstet ihr, dass dieser Song in fast jedem Game von dem Programmierer-Composer drin war?
Das war nicht nur in Undertale drin.
Das war in seinem Earthbound-Rom-Hack drin.
Das war in dieser einen Web-Comic-Serie drin.
Das war in jedem Game bisher von ihm drin.
Oder fast.
Das ist ja geil.
Wobei wir gerade dabei sind.
Undertale-Musik.
Das ist aber geil.
Also, Michael, das ist ganz schön weit hergeholt jetzt.
Die Musik war schon nice.
Also, ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, so den Mega-Hype um Undertale konnte ich nicht so ganz nachvollziehen.
Das war auf jeden Fall ein überraschendes Game mit Megamusik.
Aber...
Best Game aller Zeiten.
Ich weiß ja nicht.
Ja.
Beste.
Di-di-di-di.
Ja, für ein Ein-Mann-Projekt war das unglaublich, ja.
Aber die Musik war geil.
Das muss man schon sagen.
Das war schon nice, ja.
Oh, Mann.
Ja, aber irgendwie die YouTube-Empfehlungen sind heute nicht so der Wahnsinn, ne?
Und auch nur Crap-Empfehlungen drin.
Sleeper.
Das ist ein Sleeper-Gaming-PC.
Was soll denn ein Sleeper-Gaming-PC sein?
Ähm, einer, der immer aus ist, oder was?
Der mies ausschaut und gut ist.
Aha.
Ah, das ist quasi...
Ah, okay.
Das ist quasi ein PC, der nicht so aussieht, als, ähm...
...wird da was reißen.
Ah ja, okay.
Also, dass man quasi reinkommt und sagt, alter, was hast du da für einen ollen Kack-PC?
Und dann einschaltet und dann spielt er.
Und dann spielt er irgendwie Battlefield 5 mit 300 FPS.
Eigentlich eine coole Idee.
Spread the Beast, sechs Monate.
Big Brain, Alter.
Dankeschön, Big Brain.
Eigentlich eine coole Idee.
Eigentlich eine echt coole Idee.
Weil der PC sieht aus wie Crap, aber ist sauschnell.
Ich hab mir jetzt auch einen Tremel bestellt.
Na gut, Kokain-Panzer, das ist mit der 1080 Ti genauso.
Der 1080 Ti ist nicht viel langsamer als High-End-2080-Karten.
Ähm, und die war ja schon eine ganze Weile am Start.
Ich mein, wann kam die 1080 Ti raus?
Das ist schon 3...
Das ist schon 3 Jahre her, 4 Jahre her.
Äh, Moment, nicht 2000.
Was gebe ich denn da ein?
1080.
Guck mal, 2017.
Ja, Moment, und...
Der Chat kennt das Kommando schon.
Ich mein, das ist Mitte...
Guck mal, das ist Anfang...
Also, runden wir mal ein bisschen auf.
Die ist drei Jahre alt, eine 1080 Ti.
Drei Jahre.
Und sie ist immer noch eine absolute High-End-Karte.
Das ist halt heftig, ja.
Gibt überhaupt keinen Grund, sich was Neues zu holen.
Und auch eine 980 Ti ist ja nicht schlecht.
Oh, es gibt wieder Club-Handys.
Aber wahrscheinlich ultra teuer.
Das ist Generals 2.
Generals 2 haben so eingestellt.
Hahaha.
The watch PC-Bild.
Every time he fails, it gets faster.
Die Leute.
Oh, man.
Das ist Firestorm.
The decline of gaming.
Es gab jetzt auch dieses Jahr nicht so viel, was mich wahnsinnig geschockt hätte.
Die Video-Empfehlungen sacken.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was ich gucken soll.
Noch eine Runde Battlefield Top Plays.
Ja, wenn sonst nichts geht, guckt mir noch eine Runde Battlefield Top Plays.
Aber nicht Battlefield 5, sondern die guten Battlefield Top Plays.
Easy Python Projects.
Weiß nicht, ob das so spannend ist.
Ja, da haben wir hochgeschrieben.
How to destroy German tanks.
Ja, das muss man natürlich wissen heutzutage.
Das ist.
Was?
Wichtig.
Witcher 3 4K Raytracing?
Ok.
Das müssen wir uns jetzt mal angucken, wie das ausschaut.
Ich mein, Witcher 3 sieht doch schon auch schon gut aus, ne?
Zu dunkel, aber das Video ist halt dunkel.
Aber ich geh mir davon aus, wenn er da rausgeht.
Ich mein gut ausschaut?
Sieht doch schon, ja.
Ah, hier geht er gleich raus.
Es wird ein Witcher 4 sehr wahrscheinlich geben.
Es wäre eigentlich umgedreht sehr unrealistisch, wenn es kein Witcher 4 geben würde,
weil Witcher 3 war unglaublich erfolgreich über Jahre lang.
Witcher ist als Gwent unglaublich erfolgreich.
Das ganze Witcher-Universum wird immer noch voll angesagt.
Da gibt es garantiert ein Witcher 4.
Moment, Moment, die Spiegelung war ein bisschen merkwürdig gerade, hä?
Guckt euch das mal an.
Das sind Holzbänke und die spiegeln, als wäre es hier irgendwie so ein Battlefield-3-Metro-Fliesenwand.
Seht ihr das? Das sehe ich so ganz richtig.
Erstmal die NPCs, die ineinander stacken.
Huge-Lauf-Animation.
Ich meine, gut, das Witcher sah schon damals gut aus, ja.
Ja, ich sehe jetzt auch jetzt keine großartige RTX-On-Geschichte, oder?
Hauptsache, wir gucken es in 4K.
Hauptsache, wir gucken es in 4K in einem 1080p-Stream.
Wenn er rennt, brechen die FPS ein, das kann durchaus sein.
Die Blumen sehen ziemlich flach aus, ne?
Guckt euch das mal an.
Auf der Erde.
Also so, also...
Ich weiß jetzt nicht...
ob da jetzt so Ultra-RTX-On ist.
Ich erkenne jetzt da wenig, ehrlich gesagt.
Also zumindest jetzt hier gerade.
Vielleicht die Reflektion hier oben so an der Mauer.
Also was ist die Reflektion?
Das Licht an der Mauer vielleicht.
So ein bisschen hier auf den Dächern.
Aber großer Unterschied ist es jetzt nicht.
Ich brauche mal was mit mehr Spiegelung.
Oh, es ruckelt.
Es ruckelt, Leute.
Es ruckelt.
Habt ihr es gehört?
Im Hintergrund gerade.
Moment.
Ich pisse auf alles.
Das muss jetzt einfach noch drinnen sein.
Zumindest spielen sie die deutsche Version hier anscheinend.
Aber es hat irgendwie was Meditatives, oder?
Was macht das Kind da?
Balancieren auf einem geraden Weg.
Das sieht jetzt schon cooler aus.
Ich kann mich aber gar nicht mehr erinnern,
wie es ohne RTX-On ausgeschaut hat.
Sah das dann nicht auch fast genauso aus?
Die Bäume sahen auf jeden Fall ähnlich aus.
Die haben sich auch schon im Original-Witcher 3 immer übelst gebeugt und gedingst.
Erstmal den Mädels hinterher gucken.
So ist er halt.
Es hat schon irgendwie so was Meditatives, so das Video.
Aber es ruckelt.
Es ruckelt manchmal.
Ihr müsst mal drauf achten.
Also es fühlt sich manchmal nicht flüssig an.
Das ist jetzt Add-on hier.
Wenn er zu schnell ist, ruckelt es wahrscheinlich.
Aber so den...
Also...
Ja, das sieht super aus, ja?
Da sind wir uns einig.
Aber...
So den Ultra-RTX-On-Mega-Effekt...
Weiß ich jetzt nicht.
Das siehst du hier, wenn man auf den Weg guckt.
Wie das hier so...
Flup, Flup, Flup, Flup, Flup, Flup, Flup, Flup, Flup, Flup, Flup, Flup.
Das ruckelt übelst.
Und wir gucken uns das nur im Video an, wenn du das spielst...
Oh je.
Ja, jetzt ruckelt es hart.
Guck mal hier wie das...
Düt, düt, düt, düt, düt, düt.
Ja, hier erkennst du jetzt mal ein bisschen was.
Das sieht dann schon cool aus.
Dann lieber 60 FPS, etwas schlechter.
Ja, sehe ich auch so.
Ich bin sogar für noch mehr FPS.
Das sind so die typischen Witcher-Bäume da hinten.
Ja, sieht ganz cool aus.
Es ist jetzt nichts, wo ich sagen würde, es muss unbedingt sein.
Zumal es eh nicht spielbar ist, richtig.
Was 16 neue Spiele für PS5 und...
Moment, das können wir uns nicht angucken.
Das gucken wir uns an Silvester an.
Weil an Silvester gucken wir uns die Games an, die 2020 rauskommen.
Das haben wir letztes Jahr auch gemacht.
Kommt ein Video zur neuen Xbox.
Du meinst diesen Aschenbecher?
Weiß ich nicht.
Okay, Leute.
Wir gucken uns jetzt noch ein Battlefield-Top-Play-Video an.
Und dann muss ich wahrscheinlich auch...
Passt schon auf.
Warum highlightet der Top nicht?
Hello and welcome to the Battlefield-Top-Plays.
In today's episode is Battlefield 3 and 4 starting out with a clip from Dusty on Pearl Markets,
a game of Rush, the ACWR, in the Engineer-Class,
completely destroying the enemies that are trying to push and defuse...
Der Typ sagt jedes Mal das Gleiche.
Erstmal schön weggesprayt mit der ACR.
Was ist das überhaupt, die ACR?
Das ist die ACR, oder?
Die ACR?
Ich kann die Waffen nur noch schlecht...
Ich erkenne die nicht mehr gut aus Battlefield 4.
Natürlich brain that Gegner, was sonst?
Ja, das ist die ACR.
Ihh!
Playstation.
Das ist nicht approved, der Clip.
Konsolen-Clips werden nicht approved.
Von mir.
Nicht, dass es jemanden interessieren würde, ob ich irgendwas approve, oder nicht.
Das ist wie bei Jukes, wo nicht gemessert wird.
Boah, der hat Motion-Signals-Foff.
Fast, fast Motion-Signals-Foff.
Geht noch, geht noch krasser.
Oh, die Gegner sind wieder richtig hinlos.
Und jetzt einmal gemessert, jawoll!
Die nächsten paar Clips von Eddie sind nicht Top-Player.
Sie könnten es aber sein.
Er hat mir ein Clip von Clips gegeben, die wirklich einige der besten Clips in Battlefield 3 sind.
Aber, als wir langsam runtergehen, wird das Schuss und seine Waffe wird von der Rotor-Blade auf dem Heli blockiert.
Das ist so traurig zu sehen.
Hier ist ein Triple-Clap.
Ob er einen Triple-Clap bekommt?
Nein, er bekommt drei Hip-Markies.
Unglaublich.
Dieser hier ist wahrscheinlich mein Lieblings-Clip.
So ein epischer Jet-Sniper.
Und er bekommt einen Hip-Marker.
Aus einer verrückten Range.
So unfreundlich.
Na ja, gut.
Ah, Kill hättest du schon zahlen dürfen.
Auch nicht approved.
Da sind vier, fünf, sechs Spieler,
die ihn dort fangen.
Er bekommt einen Kill und drei Assistenzen.
Das ist einfach schmerzhaft.
Mit dem letzten Clip und 2 HP.
Ob Battlefield 4 so viel Metro gespielt wird, weiß ich nicht.
Das war immerhin DLC.
Dieser hier ist ein langer Range-Sniper.
Ein Hip-Marker.
Auf dem Stealth-Gen.
Das ist schmerzhaft zu sehen.
Und dieser hier ist wahrscheinlich der Schlimmste.
Wobei, das hat er eigentlich getroffen.
Nächster Schuss.
Ein Hip-Marker auf dem Pilot.
Bombino-Sniper kommt mit
einem anderen Rende-Bau.
Er ist in der A-10.
Auf diesem wunderschönen Paracel-Storm-Map.
Er spotiert seinen Ziel in der Distanz.
Läuft ihn mit dem Bau.
Bailt ihn aus der Strecke.
Und schießt ihn in den Jet.
Er schießt ihn mit einem riesigen Schuss.
Das war cool, oder?
Das war cool.
Das war echt cool.
Paracel-Storm-Map.
Er spotiert seinen Ziel in der Distanz.
Läuft ihn mit dem Bau.
Bailt ihn aus der Strecke.
Und schießt ihn mit einem riesigen Schuss.
Er schießt ihn mit einem riesigen Schuss.
Max, das ist nice, du.
Der sieht den Typ noch nicht mal.
Das ist jetzt kein Skill, das ist Glück.
Das ist K.K.E.L.A., ne?
Und das ist, glaub ich, ist das Konsole?
Ne, das ist keine Konsole.
Das ist PC, aber
ziemlich schlechte Videoqualität.
Das hab ich noch nicht gesehen.
Wir sind auch sehr glücklich.
Sehr glücklich, äh.
Dass das funktioniert hat.
Oh, schön durchgesprayt, äh.
Next.
Das ist Aftermath, oder?
DLC.
Again.
Ja, EpiCenter, ja.
Oh, die Gegner sind wieder so.
Oh Gott, die Gegner.
Ah, das tut weh beim Zugucken.
Oh, Nosehair.
Erstmal schön weggenau scoped.
Tzu.
Der Gegner, Alter.
Was hat er denn jetzt gedacht?
Was der macht?
Hinter der Kiste sich verstecken, bis er um die Ecke läuft, oder wie?
Okay, das ist auch sehr glücklich gewesen.
Wünscht ihr auch MPH?
Die Noobs fliegen den Heli, genau.
Aber diese Noobs hier im Video, die könnten den Heli nur nicht mal fliegen.
Also, die könnten dann eben abheben mit dem Heli.
Also, guck, die sind absolut, also, manche Gegner sind einfach absolut braindead.
Der Sound der Waffen war in Battlefield 3 schon immer so.
Ja, ist schon geil.
Guckt euch den an.
Was ist mit dem Gegner los?
Was ist mit diesem Gegner los?
Habt ihr das gerade gesehen?
Was?
Moment.
Was ist mit dem Typ neben ihm los?
Ist der, ist der irgendwie geistig besonders, oder zurückgeblieben sagt man ja nicht mehr.
Das ist ja toss.
Ich mein, guck mal.
Der steht hinter dem und macht nix.
Ey.
Tss.
Fuck!
fuck!
Vielleicht wollte er es friedlich klären.
Das kann er.
Ja, das wird es gewesen sein.
Panzifist.
Ähm.
In den Kopf.
Ich bin immer erstaunt wieder.
Öhm.
wenn man das so teilweise anguckt, mit einem guten Aufnahmegerät,
wie brauchbar doch Battlefield 3 auf den alten Konsolen noch ausschaut und lief, ja.
Ich hab ja auch lange 360 gespielt, darf man nicht vergessen.
Moment, Moment, nein, nein, nein, nein, das ist so nicht richtig.
Das ist nicht Tony Stark, das ist X, Underscore Tony Stark, Underscore X.
Man muss das schon richtig aussprechen.
Battlefield 3, Sane crossing, drops a medbag down into the back of this skip
and starts to look for the enemies.
He knows they're through this notorious chokepoint, so he rushes them with his 870 MCS.
Oh, Rush B.
Schreckt, würde ich sagen.
Wawa, Kup, was auch immer.
Wird aber eigentlich noch auf BF3 klar.
Was ist das für ein Game?
Das 4, ah, das ist Battlefield 4, ähm, dieser Dings hier, ähm, boah.
Das ist Dragon Rising DLC, äh, äh, nicht Dragon, doch, Dragon Rising war es, nicht China Rising, Dragon.
Ja, ist es, ist es.
Zack, Kack-Map, hab ich überhaupt nicht gerne gespielt.
Die haben es einfach nur eingespielt.
Die haben es einfach nur eingespielt, um viele Panzer spawnen zu können.
Zack.
Oh, erstmal schön wegmessern noch, jawoll.
Beste.
Die Sauen, der Sound von Battlefield 3 war einfach geil.
Hier ist ein Midi-Kit.
Oh.
Na, aber das war jetzt, also wenn das hittet, das, das, das war schon recht glücklich, dass der gehittet hat.
Und der andere hittet jetzt auch, oh, cool, cool.
Doch, doch, Klaus Quart, das war gut.
Ich war halt eher so der Rush-Fan, aber Klaus Quart, das ab und zu war richtig cool.
Und, und, und, bäh, nice.
Zehn Minuten gibt's vor, da waren wir.
Wie toll, John G.
Wow, will er sich kotzen, was?
Pizza-Brötchen.
Nee.
Ha, ha, ha, lull.
Den hat er cool erwischt.
Bäm.
Richtig weihnachtlich, nice.
Okay, okay, Moment.
Best Reaction, das heißt, wir müssen, wir müssen schon mal leiser machen.
Wahrscheinlich ist Freitag gleich rum.
Siehste?
Wie ich das prediktet hab, dass wir leiser machen müssen.
Liegt lieb.
Nice, okay, Leute.
Eins gucken wir noch, oder ich muss mal gucken, wie das Essen ausschaut, ja.
In zehn Minuten gibt's Essen, das war vor drei Minuten.
Okay, eins können wir noch gucken.
Die Map hab ich, glaube ich, zweimal gespielt oder so.
Ähm.
Hello and welcome to the Battlefield 4 Top Plays.
In this episode we have a selection of epic Battlefield 4.
Starting out with a few from Bomber, Sniper, this guy has forever been one of the best players on Battlefield 4.
Ah, nice.
Das ist halt heftig, ne.
Wobei ich mir bei solchen Clips manchmal die Frage stelle, ist das nicht Setup?
Achso, ja, ich kann wieder lauter machen.
Ist das nicht Setup?
Ja, manchmal bin ich mir nicht so sicher.
The fact that he manages to pull so many of these off is just awesome.
Two more clips that I'm gonna let play.
The first on Hangar 21, an insane Snipe, and then the final one.
Well, you'll just have to watch.
Oh, schau mal, da der Bogen-Typ.
Das Far Cry.
Boah.
Also, wenn das geaimt war, dann ist es nicht schlecht.
Huge Head.
A more conventional Top Play sent in from Dexter.
This one is with the AEK 971 on Zavod TDM.
We've seen a few clips like this in the past on the Top Plays,
but not for a while, and it's refreshing to see some nice infantry action
focused on good positioning and accuracy on a map that really excels for infantry gameplayers.
Das ist eine gute Map gewesen.
Fairly decent on Rush and TDM.
I think it's also really nice, especially after they removed the ladders that enable you to get...
Falsch copy-pasted.
...that was quite a few years ago.
Wo muss das sein?
AEK.
Beste.
Nice.
Weg, Sprite.
Alter, der Typ hat fünf Helms.
Ihr müsst doch einfach nur einmal draufschießen, Gegner.
Scheint äußerst komplex zu sein.
Das ist Playstation.
Bam.
Jetzt.
Das war Glück.
Das war pures Glück.
Moving over to a nice infantry clip from Sario.
The ACE 50.
CQB is his weapon of choice.
This is a lot of players.
Again on Zavod, as we saw earlier with Dexter, but this one is on Rush.
And it shows you how hectic it can actually be.
Luckily for him, he has the G18 as a secondary.
One of the best secondaries in any Battlefield 4.
Seit Battlefield 4 weiß er, dass das Fabrik auf Russisch heißt.
At times, it's so strong.
And that was a lot of kills.
Next up, a clip from Ganja Mafia.
The first, a Jetsonite on Heenan with the SRR.
Hock.
And the second.
We'll check this out for an epic only in Battlefield moment.
Hahaha.
Neonomimus, der ist gut.
Können die nicht einfach Battlefield 3 oder 5 remake?
5?
5 ist das aktuelle.
Remaken.
Nein, ich bin nicht dafür, dass sie es remaken sollten.
Sie sollten einfach ein neues, gutes Battlefield machen.
Die müssen es nicht remaken.
Weil wenn sie es remaken, wird ja im Prinzip heißen,
sie sind absolut nicht mehr fähig, ein gutes Battlefield zu machen.
Sie sollen ein neues, ordentliches Battlefield machen in der heutigen Zeit.
Mit, mit...
So vielseitig einfach, wie das 3 und 4 gewesen sind.
Something a little bit different next from DJ Royale.
Was passiert da?
This is Cesar Shanghai Bravo Objective.
And as you know, you can drive the tank under here in order to cap the flag.
He is the gunner.
He's got the incendiary grenade and the thermal,
which is really the way.
You can't go if you're a competent gunner.
Just looking to protect the tank and get as many kills as possible.
The driver also seems to know what he's doing as they sit on the flag moving around.
So they're not a stationary target.
He knows where the enemies are coming from.
Ich hoffe echt, das nächste Battlefield wird Bad Company 3.
Fly through that doorway, providing him with a load of kills.
An awesome streak.
Und halt im Battlefield Bad Company 3, was du den Abend verdienst.
Das ist ja das eigentliche Problem.
Nicht, dass sie Bad Company 3 machen, sondern Bad Company 3.
Was den Abend verdient.
Die Musik dabei war richtig gut, oder?
Fast richtig gut, wie der Panzer reinkommt.
This is how you start off a game of Goldmode.
Fui is going to be playing on Goldmode Railway.
Starting out on the Chinese side, picks the attack jet, the Q5 Phantom.
And watch what he manages to do with some supreme JDAM accuracy.
Macht er jetzt den Heli platt?
Oh!
Das war nice.
Wie er sich freut.
Ich bin immer noch am Start, ja?
Wenn auch mit anderen Sachen als damals.
Das war zur Abwechslung wirklich mal Skill und nicht einfach nur Glück.
Ey, der ist echt gut, der Typ.
Er ist ein großer Battlefield 4 Spieler und versucht immer noch sein Bestes, das Spiel zu streamen,
obwohl sich viele Influential-Faktoren versuchen, ihn davon zu verhindern.
Das ist ein episches Clip.
Cesar Shanghai nimmt das Transport-Helikopter ab, in der Distanz, mit einem Barrel.
Es ist schon geil, wie gut manche Leute mittlerweile in dem Game sind.
Ich habe es mir sehr gefreut, diese Dinge auf Battlefield 4 zu sehen, besonders live im Stream, aber er macht es zum ersten Mal.
Nachdem er davon folgt, wartet er auf den Feind-Schopper, um wieder zu spawnen.
Er wartet auf den Feind-Schopper, um wieder zu spawnen.
Und er macht es wieder mit einem anderen epischen Barrel-Roll-Toe.
Dieser Typ ist mit dem Atak-Helikopter-Toe-Missil einfach sublime.
Und er macht fast alle anderen Piloten in der Spielzeit, wie ein Amateur.
Weiter geht es mit einem Infanterie-Clip von Matty Boss.
Er ist live im Stream, ziemlich oft, und das wurde von seinem Stream-Helikopter AK-12 auf der Brünschen-Locker gedreht.
Es ist ein sehr guter Streak-Disc, und es gibt einige Momente, die mich wirklich lachen.
Die Leute denken, Camping ist schlecht in Battlefield 5.
Und obwohl es ist, ist es nicht.
Immer der Infanterie-Spieler in Battlefield.
Und ein bisschen Panzer.
Die Gegner! Alter, ihr Nix-Checker!
... in einem kleinen Hallen.
Die Konzentration der Feinde ist einfach zu hoch.
Und er wird belastet, durch einen reichen, schönen Streak-LG.
Das Slave-Data wird in ein paar Clips auf Battlefield 4 eingeladen.
Ich lasse sie im Hintergrund spielen, ohne in den Battlefield-Bremsen auf der Konsole zu spielen.
Dieses Spiel erzeugt immer noch viel Spaß für die Spieler, die sich involvieren wollen.
Es ist ziemlich frei, um diese Tage auf all diesen Origin-Aktiven zu spielen.
Auf der Konsole wird es sehr günstig gegeben.
Und Momente wie diese in der Lave sind definitiv wertvoll, um das Spiel zu bekommen.
Und es ist sehr günstig, um das Spiel zu machen.
Und ich versuche, einige Clips so zu drehen.
Zinx kommt als nächstes mit einem ziemlich ungewöhnlichen Clip.
Er spielt auf Dragon Valley.
Das ist natürlich eine Remake der klassischen Battlefield-Mappe.
Er fliegt auf die Ecke der Lave und wird von einem Feind-Aerfahrzeug geschlachtet.
Und, naja, er schießt es nicht wirklich.
Er schießt es, als solches.
Er schießt es einfach mit seiner Lave raus.
Er bekommt nicht mal den Tod, aber trotzdem.
Das ist das, was man macht, wenn man jemanden auslösen möchte, der dich lockt.
Bertifun Egoli kommt als nächstes.
Das ist ein langweiliges RPG.
Er repräsentiert die Südafrikanische Gemeinschaft, glaube ich.
Und es ist schwierig für diese Leute, Server zu finden, die in ihrer Region sind.
Ich glaube, manchmal müssen sie nicht kämpfen.
Und das ist der zweite Schuss auf dem Flugzeug.
Aber der erste Schuss wurde verloren.
Also werde ich ihn auch einschalten.
Die Dinge kommen zu Ende.
Mal gucken.
Ich habe hier Urlaub.
Und jetzt Seefeiertag.
Also ich denke mal, dass ich morgen auch am Start bin.
Also Leute, wir sehen uns.
Muss futtern.
Bis denn.
See you.
Macht's gut.